[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
might check my check make sure my levels
is good chad what's going on i see y'all
in here
salute man oh man there's a lot of
people in here danielle master clowns yo
salute much love on the super chats
definitely got to read those out
salute to the loyalty gaming about my
head of respect america much love
respect
sounded good hustling motivated on
twitch what's going on baby i already
see you yeah we got attic in the
building we're doing a mic check king on
rolling you know king rolling through
we're gonna get the invites out to the
guests i just got to do the sound check
right quick
everybody is uh anticipation is high
let's just say
let's go to regulator what's going on
what's going on bro how my levels is how
my levels is you sound fine i'm
listening no doubt trucking hollow y'all
see i hear attic
yeah what's up guys i'm here okay okay i
saw people making the slide little
gestures about attic oversleep and
everything attic oversleep one show
and then everyone acting like i'm never
on time
[Music]
trucker hat hollow what's up east texas
alex t what's up
oh twitch what's going on baby black
round black rain clouds i like that
so let me get the invites out to the
people thank y'all for the mug chat
mocha smiley what's up
[Music]
we got to get a lot of people oh cedric
hey thank you brother
let's go file some chat you don't know
what time it is
definitely hit that like button man
let's get those like so let's show
everyone that that the realm is live
go go go on the go on that that twitter
man tell everybody this is the place to
watch no doubt so we're gonna get these
invites out to the guests lucha for a
little bit
and then we roll it over all right
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right mike check my check shout out
to jay a welcome to the realm welcome to
the realm man so we're going to all
transition and the king of zen wilmy zen
boom is in that singers in wilhelm
screen is in blaze going to join us in
progress and hopefully solve for joining
us in progress so we're going to switch
over now howdy going to hit that twitch
one up
yeah i would get the twitch one up it
just has a you know what's funny
twitch is not um
[Music]
live i mean xbox is not uh live on
twitch this year
that's weird yeah because it's the nine
minutes of the show dude yeah i'm
refreshing let me know if y'all see it
on your side uh youtube we're not gonna
do it on what you're gonna call it on
the game award yeah yeah that's right
that's why i'm watching it right now
that's been up all the whole time okay
yeah
it's been about an hour yeah
let me put that sound down on that yeah
that's on zero all right
boom congratulations brother oh thank
you congratulations
all right let me know how the levels
sound
you sound good dude i'm good
but i want to know how to stream if
y'all hear the beat because it sounds
really loud and nice on my side but i
want to know how to chat let us know how
that sounds in relation to our voices
this is uh this is the day we've been
waiting for gentlemen
yes sir
don't phil gave me the call yesterday
how much straight butter if you got it
oh man hold on one second y'all so akw
jd i say we sound good yeah they do okay
cool now the beat got hearing that
good all right it's a little loud i
actually like that dt
it's slightly louder music that is okay
if it's too loud
then i'll turn down a little bit
i don't want us to miss anything out of
us to overtalk and big announcements
all right cool y'all can talk now
since you say that's my guy
give him that respect that joint right
there i think um the last video
that i put up on
in the last video
that went wild bananas
that joint
is it 17
[Music]
in xbox history the legendary
legendary white gloves and all
doing it with major nelson
what
my boy is out here
thank you dude appreciate this matter of
fact uh if you become a channel member
uh i added the white gloves emoji
[Music]
that is a plus marking sir
[Music]
oh mariota find out somebody get your
terror flaps out you know already if you
say congrats to the boom thanks thank
you dude super appreciate it
what's going on hit the like button
[Music]
what's up brother make sure this is my
guys what's going on bro
nintendo represent h obama what's going
on i see you
boom the beard is in there oh my man
kofi hit me he was like yo i can't even
front that went hard as hell
uh
[Music]
[Music]
i mean playstation dudes is even like yo
i came from that that's that's
what's up
[Music]
oh yeah i'm gonna shave my hawk is ready
[Music]
what's going on
i think that we are all going to walk
away from this show
truly impressed
i'm ready man i'm so ready it is time
yes i agree
my favorite part thank you
what's up
he said phil maximus
soon to be done now he already dominance
he's soon to be aurelius
yes
my question is when does king don that
that's what i wanna do
um
it's a couple of things that can form
them to get aurelius like like he got
dominus
out of out of pure domination
out of pure fighting you know uh
he got maximus
when um
satya
you know understood
who he had on his team like that when
when when you feel when you phil jackson
and you look at you like yo i got jordan
on the squad what the deal oatmeal and i
gotta respect this dude i gotta make
sure that he got these shooters around
so he could do his thing you know so he
could clear the lane for my man
and you know um
and it takes a dude because a lot of
dudes have given greeny a lot of flack
yeah
green greeny is the scottie pippen of
this man
[Music]
you know so you have to manage your team
properly and
i think by phil making sure that certain
dissensions was all for the ranks
you know dudes know what i'm talking
about you know what it is
um it flowed better it smelled better
it's a bigger day it's a better day so
um aurelius might happen today whoa
i really this might happen today i i
don't wanna i don't wanna give him a
really us yet because
you know what it has to be
aurelius has to be
when the playstation shoot they shot in
august
and
they undercut them and take their knees
out
like
you gotta you gotta be stronger than
them
you gotta be
uh cheaper than them
you you have to put yourself in position
where they
[Music]
thank you brother i appreciate it thank
you
all right so let's get regulator
2000 that's my guy good morning lords
and panel let's go got to feel dominance
is up oh you know what i'm saying oh man
we got a bunch and oh bro mocha again
right at this moment right at this time
i'm simply happy no doubt
[Music]
[Music]
yes he'd be deboning us we're all scared
everybody's on the best behavior you
notice
as long as he's where i can see him
when you can't see him he out there
doing things
[Music]
good morning lords and mr boom time
yo make sure y'all go and uh retweet
that tweet that i put out man go go get
amped up go watch that real quick go get
them get get get get the old spark in
your chest get your chest sparked up
[Music]
we are 60 seconds from the start
gentlemen i got 30 seconds
okay okay yeah another 30 seconds
christopher stop hating i see you
what's good
did i ever tell the lord the most
spectacular votes yes because of the
graphic one himself crappy god my god
man thank you brother you always do it
yeah cyber knocks what's going on
brother i've seen you in the video
what's up man
wilbon
[Music]
i said no i will mute you guys if it
gets too long
cause we can follow the chat you missed
my first one corrupt cod i see how you
do me yeah you gotta be nice to me then
i read them
hello everybody it's jeff keely and
welcome to this special xbox game
showcase and our pre-show here leading
up to the big main showcase that happens
in one hour at the top of the next hour
uh welcome to youtube gaming and our
exclusive coverage this obviously is uh
a different year for all of us in 2020
and normally every year i love getting
together with everyone around the world
to watch all the e3 events but this year
of course uh given where the world's at
we're doing things
like
before we get into this i certainly want
to acknowledge uh everything that is
still happening around the world
um and i certainly hope everyone is
safe and uh feeling okay today and
excited about video games you guys here
i think my mind has been a source of
comfort for many of us in 2020 so today
is really about wait a minute
celebrating games and the future of what
the hell i'm saying
um in the future you know this is still
games and that new consoles are
launching and today is all about xbox
and the xbox series x is coming out this
holiday season although today is less
about hardware and is going to be more
about the model
and in our pre-show we've got a lot of
great guests joining us to preview what
we expect from xbox we also have some
world premieres and some great new game
stuff to show you guys as well
uh the xbox story for series x of course
started last year at the game awards
when we revealed the xbox series x
hardware on stage i uh i certainly
miss memories of thousands of people
together and the excitement of shocking
the world with that announcement last
year uh that was such a special moment
that no one had any clue it was about to
happen and we've revealed the hardware
there
but of course everyone wants to know
about the games that are going to run on
the system and today
is all about a game that was
sort of mentioned in that teaser halo
halo infinite we are going to get a
first look at the game play of the
campaign of halo infinite in the xbox
game showcase um that's something that
we're all very excited to see i'm sure
we'll be talking about that a lot over
the next hour uh and xbox has already
said we're not gonna hear a lot about
hardware today we don't expect to hear
the release date for series x we don't
expect to hear about pricing um it
really is going to be a showcase all
about games and focused a lot more on
their first party studios meaning games
that are coming exclusively um to the
xbox ecosystem which of course includes
game pass
and pc and even ex
there's a lot to talk about kind of what
xbox is doing with gaming and their
approach um so we've got some world
premieres for you and we've got a lot of
guests so let's get ready for this
58 minutes away from the show
before we get to our first world
premiere though
i want to welcome some panelists to talk
about what we're expecting today from
xbox so first up joining me is my good
buddy jacksepticeye my daughter go crazy
for that dude
my daughter los angeles we've also got
lauren's side here
legend
i'm doing fantastic good to see you as
well and finally we've got a guy who uh
who got to go up to microsoft and check
out the xbox series x hardware before
lockdown austin evans austin it's good
to have you with us matt
hey jeff thanks for having me man
yeah great to have all you guys here so
let's kick things off here by talking
about tech legends what you want to see
like yeah what's going on
what are your expectations as as fans of
games what what do you want to see
big elephant in the room the big chief
elephant in the room is everyone just
wants to see halo infinite and i'm
really curious because i'm not the
biggest halo fan but this even this one
has kind of gotten me intrigued and
excited so i'm curious to see about that
i want to see more hellblade 2 if we're
going to get some of that because the
when we saw that trailer at the game
awards and we were sitting in that
theater and that music kicked in and
rocked everyone's socks i was really
impressed with that and seeing what the
hardware could kind of do
an engine there um i'm a sucker for from
soft games i
my heart's going to be broken when we
don't see eldon ring today but it's been
so long since it was announced i need to
see it somewhere
and see that it still exists and as long
as i get a good world premiere i'll be
happy
oh wait wait wait we got the world
premiere voice guy actually doing the
voice here when we come to our facebook
page
it's crazy we're here to take
care of you but yes as you said uh you
know everyone would love to see
feel like halo was like my first
introduction into
i'm big into like psychological horror
games
so the medium i really really want to
see more about i want to see gameplay
they haven't told us a whole lot about
it um but i'm i'm living for it like the
silent hill music everything
[Music]
both of those are kind of a mystery i
haven't i haven't seen much i want you
to steal all breath of the wild that's
great because as you said there are lots
of other games across the studios every
while that they teased last year at exo
from rare looking really interesting i
agree hopefully we'll get to see
something on that tim schaefer's got uh
psychonauts
acquired that studio hopefully there'll
be an update on that one and and he said
microsoft's got so many studios so many
games um across the portfolio that i
think we'll get hopefully some new game
announcements
you know got to check out uh series x
you got a little uzi check it out here's
how that was in the hardware and
everything like that so you have a
really perspective
the nerdy details right i want to see
the 120 fps and the hdr and
all the the ray tracing i'm really
interested in seeing kind of like what
this next generation is able to do what
time do you guys start selling the
wheelchair right i mean
don't get me wrong
especially considering that that's going
to be a game no it comes with a bottle
um
more than anything else right so that
definitely has like a special place in
my heart from the gaming side but what
i'm really curious about
is getting a really good look at kind of
what this new slate of time is obviously
we know that there are a bunch of games
that are coming out sort of holiday
season yeah we're probably going to get
through we're probably going to see some
games kind of reveal those things for
the next maybe a year or two or whatever
the case is but i really want to see a
good sense of what the xbox series x is
capable of right i've seen little bits
and pieces i got to try a couple of tech
demos i know the specs i know all the
kind of basic stuff
how is christopher
you're throwing some strings
oh infinite with question marks
you know how powerful this console is
like we want to see that power right and
see what this is able to do and
microsoft
philosophy on point xbox that phil
spencer has expressed is a little bit
different than the playstation that
they're saying that all these games are
going to show you today considerably
will still work on your current xbox
pc and they might you know they work
better on the new xbox but i'm curious
for you guys
how does that affect your sort of
decision on what you're going to do with
xbox like what's going to cause you to
want to upgrade to the next system
because it's it's different that you
know halo as you said will work probably
on if you have an xbox right now it'll
work on the current system
i assume part of what they have to show
today is i like i like what you can use
better on the next one what what do they
need they they need
tcl
yeah i think for me
what i like most about the xbox one
if anybody's so much like we always get
sony with theirs
everything i only use my playstation for
gaming but i really use my xbox for
almost everything i watch netflix on it
i watch movies and i play my my 4k
blu-ray what are you sipping on ace of
spades playstation couldn't do that
be playable on the new one they keep
talking about backwards compatibility
and i'm curious to see how far that goes
and how many games
and how far they're pushing it and stuff
like game pass has come out and it's
it's kind of a game changer because
there's so many times when i just go on
wallet i don't want to buy a new game
but it's game pass is a good way of kind
of trying it out and testing it
away i really love that aspect so i want
to see how far they push that and x
cloud i think they wow
will
at least for me personally the way i
consume the the media on my xbox
yeah no i think that i don't know about
the game is another big part of it you
know a lot of these games
as part of game passing microsoft said
kind of all their first party titles
people sample more games right it's no
longer like you have to spend 60 dollars
to play everything like this
i want to ask you about the
the specs and the you know the frame
rates and all that type of stuff you
know you live in the world of tech and
you know our dna architectures and
whatnot like what do you think
what does that all mean to the gamers
how do you think the games are going to
be wonderful
at least
so i think the interesting way of
looking at sort of the previous
generation
is coming from going
one it had good graphics it was able to
provide really impressive games
like red dead two running on an original
xbox one it's really impressive that
that was able to be sort of that's nice
i accomplished put the 88 inches
though with the series x we have not
only the ssd which is going to very
quickly get used to not
minute load times but you know a few
second load times but also you have that
really powerful cpu which is going to
enable these bigger open worlds sort of
more interesting looking physics and
then you have on the graphics side not
only sort of more
digital i think the higher frame rates
are something that especially as more
and more
people are going to really start to
appreciate but also these new features
like ray tracing right which are just
going to help ground these worlds in a
much more sort of realistic sort of
location like i guess for me it's more
about making the console a much more
complete packaging you're not
sacrificing because you're
playing on your pc versus your account
you're going to be learning a very
similar level of performance in a lot of
cases something like the series x is
going to be significantly more powerful
than any other gaming device
i got a problem all right well hopefully
we're going to get to see some of that
lauren you get the last word here
anything you're hoping is a surprise
today you talked about some of the games
we know about like the medium and
everwild anything that you're secretly
hoping they they show here in some way
please ah dudes didn't know what they
were you know i was listening to the
show yesterday to see if there was
a 100 surprises
with more like xbox exclusive exclusives
um i mean game pass has been a game let
you guys know that if i hear the killer
thing so just like bringing me into that
system
they've surprised me so no that madness
that's part of what they're trying to do
here is you said you know you play all
this stuff for your pc you can play you
know on your phone via xcloud and like
you know bring indoor games
hopefully we'll see a bunch of games
today right and we know halo is going to
be a big focus
of some stuff that uh will be coming to
xbox and we're going to start right now
with this world premiere announcement
check it out
half dozen bro that's a lot
dragon quest holy [ __ ] square oh
my god this is a good look wow this
would never come carnation of this
the first
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is one of the biggest
franchises
[Music]
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
yeah
there you go dragon quest coming for the
first time to xbox and now we're gonna
get right into another world premiere
this is a brand new game announcement um
a smaller team and studio that has a new
title to announce uh today on the
pre-show so take a look
smaller team getting bizet let's get it
twisted
ray tracing
just some real ray tracer
this is halo in the beta form
yo
yo
yes
well you know what it is it's called ray
tracing to the next
[Music]
we do have
more new uh games and some cool stuff
we've got something very cool to wrap up
the pre-show is our last premiere that
i'm really excited to share with you
guys um so stick around and of course at
the top of the hour we're going to get a
look at a lot of the first party games
uh from microsoft including the world
gameplay debut of halo infinite uh right
now though we're going to turn to our
second panel as we preview what we're
hoping all our hopes and dreams for xbox
today uh joining me first off is aaron
hanson from the game grumps aaron you
ready for blanks
oh dude they do blink
i was all like i'll blink stuck online
crying waiting all summer for this
moment
all right
we've got danny o'dwyer from uh no club
hey danny how you doing hey how are you
doing man i'm just really happy to to
for uh aaron to get him talking about
waiting for her
was it a month
playstation from twitch forget all these
all these new studios and all these new
games that all their acquisitions are
gonna do it's it's all about the blinks
bring back the time sweeper right that's
clearly the closure of the show right
you must know something uh and finally
we've got alana pierce joining us hey
elena hey how you doing
i'm doing great all right you're all
chipper we're ready to go this is xbox
day
hopefully some excitement
um for all of us uh with what xbox has
in store so we joked about uh blinks but
xbox has
a lot of franchises a lot of history in
gaming over the past uh 20 years i'm
going to open with the same question i
had for the last panel
what are your hopes what are your
expectations what what do you want to
see
from xbox in this next hour that's gonna
you know just convince you
they've got a lot of great stuff from
the you know charting the future
camera okay aaron let's take blinks off
the table beyond that whatever
today
uh well you know if i'm going to be
honest man i want to know what the heck
is going on with exo mecca because that
like fire i was not expecting something
like that and
holy crap
reaction yeah that appealed to like my
80s early 90s
culture
mind i was just like it's just big
silver robots punching each other and
there's a robot dragon i guess new
generation
great man
over and over all right
like what is xbox what does xbox have to
do today what do you want to see in this
hour showcase
well we've had uh microsoft
you know doing a lot of acquisitions
over the past couple of years um and a
lot of studios that were sort of working
on games perhaps or working on smaller
games
i think what i'm excited for today is
for a bunch of those
studios to maybe show something off so
one studio we visited earlier this year
that was obsidian
before working on
groundwater um
and there's a lot of rumor the
playground who work on the forza series
yeah they have sort of taken up the
mantle on that and it's been rumored
that they've been working on some sort
of open world world playing game as well
so those are kind of the two that i'm
looking to see and just anything else
from the rest of their acquisitions like
double fight i'm sure they're not
they're the small teams i'm sure they're
not running multiple projects of course
you know you never know maybe they're an
early concept phase on something
no i think rpgs is a great
genre right we're tired from like xbox
we've done lots of action games but uh
doing rpg stuff i think is some an
opportunity for them
also blinks no i'm kidding um i i love
fable i really want a new favorite like
danny said
uh it's rumored that playground games
are working on it and i think everyone
they hired a lot of people from uh a lot
of studios as making really big names
including rockstar um and gorilla uh so
i i really like tom blaze showed up i
love that world
there's something so pleasant about it
what a british rpg like the the huge
no i think you're right there's such an
interesting story there
what's happening with xbox live game
pass this idea of you know having the
you know subscriptions
right versus buying it
again it seems like part of microsoft's
approaches you know very netflix-like
and that you're going to sort of get all
these games all this content and that'll
mean
games but also you know smaller games
that people are more likely to sample uh
thank you you know huge opportunity to
see a diversity
um let's talk about
halogen levels
yesterday was like very reminiscent of
the original halo combat evolved um we
know we're going to see the campaign
today we saw it was last year at e3 we
saw kind of a we've actually passed two
e3s we saw kind of teaser assets for
infinite originally we saw kind of the
engine and then last year we saw you
know sort of an in game sequence uh or
at least rendered in engine um
what do you guys what are your hopes
what what does halo have to do um you
know obviously a legendary franchise i
think there's a big opportunity here for
them but it's a very competitive space
uh
with first person action games right now
um what do you want to see in a new halo
what what will convince you that uh halo
is back on top more chief what's left
less lock
that's my number one um i think we'll
get that
contract right
um an interesting one and then i don't
want it to shift too far from classic
halo because that's
sort of been with me my whole life
um but i would also same token like a a
story like an odst i really liked the
way that that was told i feel like
that's really unlikely but i want a
groundbreaking story uh i want something
that kicks me in the feels like reach
did or like odst did cause odsd those
people dying
the nerdiness of probably a halo 2
just as long as chief's with me the
whole way i'm going to be good though
it's not like lockslam yes as you said
you know what i'm focused on people
don't like that
other people to control the style of
gameplay controlling like danny you know
we see those two person games going in
different directions
do you think does that still hold up in
2020 or what do you think that should be
when you see this
demo or gameplay footage what are you
going to be looking for that's going to
cue to you like halo's back
yeah i think that's the big sort of
question on this um
when we first saw infinite it was around
the time that that big sort of shift
into games as a service was happening um
where games like uh the division and i
mean destiny is obviously the
most obvious one where we're turning
into these platforms that we're getting
catered to in new content over and over
and over again and obviously the word
infinite sort of implies
something along those lines um so i'm
really interested in this type of game
when it first came around
like we re emerging
it was very much a game that was pushing
both single player and multiplayer
and the other side of it that i'm really
interested in is just how the slip space
engine works because they've had
[Music]
is
[Music]
what's going to convince you that uh
this is the first person to see a dude
walk in the background with a hoodie and
just turn this stuff
for me yellow
multiplayer right so like i was never
huge for the single player campaigns i
always played online always played with
friends you see what this is right i
mean
really is this right there's sort of
like an xbox dedication to the old
hill my god you know that i already know
you're getting a series x anyway
they can like modernize that and make it
but i'll play my playstation every three
years you know like it feels new it
doesn't feel like oh they're just really
re-releasing what are you like
baby
danny that they're gonna destiny affy
the single player campaign which is a
very
a profitable thing to do so i get why
studios want to do that but i'm scared
yeah i know you said how they blend
single multiplayer and it sounds like
they're talking about campaigns i don't
know if we're even going to get much on
the multiplayer so you said how that's
all going to blend together and how
they're going to be kind of explain what
it is right and that's part of the thing
with these streams sometimes we see lots
of footage but then we have
questions afterwards
what is this
uh
uh we don't know where it's going to
start or where it's going to end
what we're talking about
is
the live xbox
ladies and gentlemen
london oh okay we already know what
we're doing
let me know because i didn't watch you
let me know if this is the train the
same trailer they used
i'm sorry we've got the best man on the
case
because if anyone it's the same exact
trailer exactly
oh
nice
looks like we're recruiting
it's yeah that's the same one
and
shadows
so i'm close
oh
[Music]
city needs a resistance
and it starts with you i think this
trailer is a little different
to the resistance
is different y'all
yeah let's just change that i didn't see
the spray paint
and stuff like that and that spring
kicked to the drawer
this first face
they they showed it in 1440p is
different when it's in 4k oh man there
we go
i need to turn the tcl up
all right well as we've mentioned quite
a few times we are going to get a first
look at the campaign of halo anybody
i asked a
friend of mine what he wants to see in a
brand new halo uh you may know ninja for
many things um over the past few years
but he actually started
and
created quite a stir with all his
awesome halo gaming and
gameplay take it away ninja
thanks jeff i'm excited to see what xbox
has a story
and here's what i want out of halo
if halo infinite can just give us a
incredible campaign to close out
the classic series
uh with a a beautiful ending
and a matchmaking such multiplayer
system where the rankings already
collected his money why aren't you here
they need to do the same thing to halo
as santa monica did the god of war don't
tell kingdom
you mean like the what we're watching
right yeah awesome
how much of that comes through hopefully
at the top of the hour
halo infinite thanks to no not echo
thank you for joining us
oh you're right i do hear it a little
bit yeah
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
now it's time
[Music]
hey what's going on guys my name is
[Music]
go ahead and collect them
in
i
xbox i have it right here yes this is
jesus remember
[Laughter]
is
definitely in minecraft
[Music]
the five games that i'm looking forward
to them announcing today so the first
one is halo alpha i came into hell late
with halo 5. i know i know but i love
this so much and i can't wait to see
what's next then there's a new game from
rare called everwile it just looks
amazing of breathtaking
we're talking about gears why not a
lego's gear slider
what about lego like i would actually
like to play that so i can't announce
that today i took the whole rub here
into the face before coming in once
it's one of the most unforgiving games
i've ever worked for for some reason
why do i want more
yes
the energizer bunnies
all around
we'll also have some creators join us
youtube gaming videos you've probably
seen check this out world premiere
another one
y'all didn't see none of this
said a new hello neighbor because they
just gave them hello neighbors
[Music]
xbox one series x
he ended up cooking food in other
people's houses
right here
this is me sleeping in the king's house
trying to get my knees back
okay so you saw what he just did right
he turned on the stove put a joint on it
put a camera up
dude come downstairs i'm like what the
hell and looked out the window this is
the wheel go pedro said
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you know what that is you know who that
is dr king that's blaze man he's trying
to prevent you from getting that series
oh yo he took his knees out son
he
oh and he got a crowbar to get up out
the window yo
i don't like the way young man we got a
blue got a
[Music]
yo i don't like how you chase it up like
that
so the playstation just got hello
neighbor 1.
there it is hello neighbor
2
and we've got some more games still to
come and we are 14 minutes away from the
start of the showcase
everybody's going to last almost exactly
one hour
15 minutes and then our post show
afterwards you're right but right now
we're going to take the first
xbox program
a great program this week actually if
you're on xbox there's a summer game
less demo event over 70 games
download and preview for free uh one of
the
things i wanted to
and i want to thank the team at xbox for
putting that together in these unusual
circumstances where we don't have big uh
consumer events to go and play
right now let's take a look at ideas
check it out here we go get all this
stuff out of all this indies in here i'm
all about
indies
because if this would have been the show
get the indies in baby
i like that game we have an interview
with that dude yeah
oh that's that game that you like
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah just the game i wanted
to keep showing this game
until it comes out that's our people's
right song of iron i'm about that
vikings
i'm oh i'm in i'm in on that one
now how can we get a new snowboarding
game
[Music]
yeah yo coco nexus said phil said you
got a project fashion project send it
straight to the pre-show
is that all this is optimized for series
whatever you see you got ray traces
snowboarding game i missed my ssx
[Music]
and when i saw this
a special
creator gaming jefferson world premiere
oh buddy
oh my oh my oh looks like some nintendo
misses
oh squares
oh
is
oh
foreign
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
oh
this is the game this is the work in
progress this is it
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and it looks kind of like cameo like
it's doing things for cameos yeah it
sure does that's a good analogy or
something
yeah it's
we'll see
says triple a better
rather pull my teeth
out of your legs
give me an ice pick
[Music]
[Music]
left by the show
there it is the announcement of ballon
wonderland uh knights was such a
special and important game to me
pakistan and square enix oh please drop
battle i don't want that beat in the
main show
there's even more good stuff though
coming up at the top of the hour
five minutes uh
that's an exciting announcement what's
happening yeah just to have those guys
back doing that so yeah i agree with you
about that all right we've also got
where he's joining us
i'm looking at this countdown for the
showcase i'm ready to put my helmet
going
we got five minutes and uh yeah joining
us also all these games
that we would have never seen hey i'm
really good i would have been happy
play them you gonna play you can post it
on twitter and go right now
you guys are gonna enjoy
this game would have come out at the end
of the sale
what else what do you guys do
right
if you have uh if it's not a nice pc
that you can run right now for the
earlier xbox you can do it on screen
and wonderland sprint 2021 will be a
retail giveaway
or fell in wonder world
yeah
wow
basically the appetizer and i i really
thought that rpg was dope i mean
obviously halo this is an appetizer i'd
ask
and use it
to be showcased
is pretty much what i would also want in
the post show which is
interesting sort of inventive newer ip
like i'm not a big you know halo nerd or
watch dogs or just anything with a
number after it unless it's some like
bizarre number that has nothing to do
with it
good emphasis on that because it really
you know
final fantasy exclusive that's making
its way onto the xbox uh for the first
time or just some game we've never heard
of before from some small exciting
studio and that's always what we're
doing if you love how the timer works
the timer has went away really true if
you got a t-o-t-c
you never know i think he's in berlin
with matrix but hey it's virtual so
anyone can this thing is this year
anyone can show up because around the
world you can connect people
and it's so different to not be with you
guys you know with 5000 people at the
microsoft theater getting to see this
stuff but we are literally uh just about
a minute away
from
your master chief helmet um and i want
to thank everyone for joining us
exclusively here
yeah
yeah absolutely like start with the big
gun
and then everything else is kind of
icing on the cake
it's gonna be halo which for someone who
doesn't really care about halo i would
love because i need a bathroom break so
sorry
the chat just lit up he's going to take
a bathroom break
all right but hey we got ballon and yeah
that's
um
allegra thanks for joining us you guys
are going to be with us afterwards we're
going to react to the press conference
see how microsoft did and then we're
going to have some guests some of the
developers and some of the games
we're going to have interviews with them
and xboxes aaron green will be joining
us live to uh break down some of the
news
show books enjoy it watch it live here
the xbox games showcase an hour of games
right here on youtube here we go
one
let's go
money's going to start let's see what it
is the big start
i like the way she do it
let's go peggy 18. did y'all go switch
to the xbox channel
did they just switch to the xbox they
switched to
[Music]
[Music]
i like this transition better anyway so
far
let's get it give showcase this is it
ladies and gentlemen
let's get it oh
oh let's start off with halo baby
yeah that's halo you want to see oh
that's halo
oh uh hey dizzy
what's up here right now what's going on
right now you're right halo
it's probably making the armor
[Music]
the hell is
this face
it's
[Music]
humanity in the war to come
liquid crystal cannot rise on its own
titanium alloy cannot prevail in the
face of extinction
sevens get it
i love this going back to the boutique
assets baby let's take it to the s's
it's sellmatic oh look at the face it
all means
[Music]
because you know the gameplay laws if we
don't get no gameplay the gameplay law
is going to be out here
so we see a press start button the demo
so they starting off good it's starting
off good let's get it i must be i mean
[ __ ] right
oh that's 60 frames like crazy
that's it that might be 16 what is it
hold up
oh
smitty smith
just do it
it's a wake up man no that's only show
put you to sleep
stanley
you breathe no
you don't get to tell me what to do you
don't get to tell me anything weird
are you even listening i count three and
here oh he probably gonna take those
hands out
ahead of me oh i'll be safe
safe do you see the particle effects i
haven't been safe since i found you the
frame right now remember
it wasn't for me
i thought i was going home
there won't be a home if we don't stop
[Music]
i'm going to dig through them and find
one
when i get back we can look it'll mind
you this is 1080p
i don't know
when you see it later
oh my god
oh my god
dude do you see the transition that
transition from real time to the game oh
my god
this is bananas folks
oh my god
[Music]
just keep up youtube yeah you oh they're
way ahead on twitch too i'm going to
tutorials
go to go to twitch i'm going to go to
twitch y'all
you know what i'm saying
they in the game this is game play y'all
oh this looks nice
wow it's the frames it's silky
[Music]
the soundtrack man that's crazy i'm
sorry
oh
oh there's the banish
switch all right all right i'm going i'm
going oh
i'm sorry
there we go oh yeah
oh shield up yo let's go oh grappling
oh that looks much better
absolutely this is huge dude i i just
gotta see how they're gonna do this
story
look at the world look at the world yeah
look at look how it's just the
smoothness of it but you know the scope
is tremendous in the skybox
master chief is back in a big way man
yo
mm-hmm
oh that dude caught all that work
oh that gun is joe yes
oh you mean
i got you frank
he said the model in action is last year
uh-huh
it does look simple yeah
it doesn't pop out much i will say the
regulator
chat let's just wait till we get that 4k
yeah
oh that's dope
toss it
dude this is this is this is wow man wow
oh get inside that's right
so this is the last time i heard him
talk about gameplay right knock your
mouth out
yeah it's looking like the movement's
gone from halo 5
so it looks like classic halo right
yeah very very good
did everybody see a boost here
huh
i've seen ads but i've not seen any of
the movement from 805. anchorman says
halo demo available now
what
excuse me make a man repeat yourself sir
hold up stop talking what's going on
here
that's not atriox
[Music]
i wish i could tell you it was difficult
but it wasn't
you [ __ ] heads up
we are one step ahead
oh
the ring is already under our control
soon
that's who you're talking
we fight together to honor the will
of atriox
[Music]
he already set his playstation on fire
oh my god
we told you we're the most powerful
why you worrying about that whack excess
d that's it
that's how they show
yo what's on the show
shut up that's coming up it's a holiday
2020 what you all say
to be continued
exactly
right we hope you enjoyed your five
years
i'm incredibly proud of the team at 343.
i'm totally thrilled to share
of the epic battles that await you on
the next chapter of master chief's
journey
this is the most ambitious campaign
we've ever created at 343. for the first
time players will have the freedom to
explore a mysterious new halo ring
that's several times larger than our
last two halo games combined can i tell
you game of thrones hill infinite has
been built from the ground up to take
full advantage of xbox series x bigger
battles epic vistas
more complex visual effects displayed
10 times the processing power per pixel
wow this will be running smallest 60
frames per second will allow us to very
much
that have never been
the frames the lighting forward
even more effectively
you can see something you can go to
including the first look at multiplayer
yeah
the models look like super clean so you
can work
oh yes this feels very help lady
no no never mind
man
this looks this kind of looks like the
third
yeah oh my god
no don't let that be the model
gotta give addict some props he was
right about halo starting not ending the
show
don't let that be the model
don't listen
i mean this is the new state of the game
do not let this be don't let this be the
graphics
do not let this be the graphics
i don't think this stage is okay this
does look like they're kind of world
still blaze said to see guys
yeah but if this is the graphics if this
is good if this is real-time
if this is real-time
we gonna have a problem just not even
buy a playstation
yo i'm about her adventure if this is
real tough
is she out here tasting blood
i bet you this is a compulsions game
that'd be nice
is
they couldn't be quiet that long let's
go welcome everyone phil tomlin put the
dominance in the chat y'all y'all know
what time it is today
from nineveh did you guys even notice
you can see the logo on her beanie
are harnessing their passions to bring
their dreams to life
we believe that how you find and play
your games is as important as the device
you play them on
xbox game pass is the best way to
discover and play
and we want you to be able to experience
as many great games as possible
so game pass members
you can play every game you see today
from your subscription or free to play
these games will look and play best on
xbox series x
delivering unmatched fidelity
precision and immersion and we've
designed the most consistently powerful
next generation console
and we've built state-of-the-art
platform technology to allow every
developer to realize their full vision
and they're early in development on the
next forza motorsport oh and xbox series
is bringing them closer to their dream
unprecedented realism with ray tracing
and native 4k resolution all wow at 60
frames per second
the trailer you're about to see was
captured
five in the bush
my god with the power
so many of you must take evasive
maneuvers dude
i got a real weak egg
yo
said xbox sold me
yo dc they doing a really good job in
this main show so far over footage
captured in engine
it's only got to see it
look at this
look crazy
they didn't number it though it's like
rebooting it yes
this looks just like it is found in this
smallest top
not bro the animation's a little late
this is gameplay
[Music]
this look it's like a pixar joint are
you crazy
[Music]
moments of stillness that look fire
christopher don't even start
wow the next vlog it looks good but so
many were so similar games yeah not like
it just
i'm gonna figure it out when it comes to
game pass
our world
has already i'm going to buy my word
real sense yeah i'm getting avatar vibes
too that's exactly what i was thinking
about
you're like
truly
to me i'm sorry i know i'm capping yeah
i could say i got this look crazy to me
i did not think i would like
this i mean
you guys can have that i'm all about it
all be i'll have it all i'll be all into
that everwild will give to you okay a
magical that's 60 frames a second
for you to explore and to just truly
lose yourself in
it's a place to be eternal
an eternal has the gift to sense and
feel how magic flows through nature the
camera game is better too every living i
ain't saying that about that right
the team here at rare are so excited to
be working on something like everwild
and i hope you're excited
but i just want to take this opportunity
to say a massive massive thank you to
everyone who's shown their support and
love
and for the incredible
awesome positive community that's
already growing around this game thank
you thank you thank you
i like the pacing though man the
pacing's on
i like that they keep going
oh this is that one game
this is the people who make life is
strange you've seen what i'm saying
i mean they look way better bunch of
filler man nah this look way better oh
well this is game pad stuff remember
stuff that i'm actually going to touch
oh my god her face looked better than
anything on playstation
it doesn't matter that finding the truth
it feels impossible
blaze you know what makes this way
different game we're done with fairy
tales you're right now you're right i
don't you guys don't got a paper
[Music]
you got a choice
really emotional
a lot of people like this game yeah
people don't like don't know everything
we thought we knew
[Music]
it looks clean as hell
[Music]
to give them credit for that it's not
just all over the shoulder
oh my god boom i like you and willie i
like you please man i like you
guys tell me why you guys jumped
available august
27th game pass eyes
that's your new name
oh that's an august 2017.
it's on point that's a multi-player two
weeks that's a multi-player new studio
hey everyone oh my name is gennady i'm
the co-founder and director of the
studio
today we are very excited to tell you
that we're working on a very very
special version of ori and the will of
the wisps specifically for xbox series
where we can reach levels of fidelity
and frame rates previously absolutely
impossible on any console
and already 120 frames
can now run at a hundred dollars
well there
and with all of this crazy hardware
power okay we can give our players more
options with how they want to play our
game
we can call me a cup right where we
experience this very special version of
ori yo i'm finished
with smart delivery
[Music]
an
and scandalous strangers greetings
attractive patreon you are looking
downright unlawful today
with the right kind of case they wanted
us to develop a miracle drugs
[Music]
what will you find
on gorgon
all right we got dates
yo stupid yo you stupid
eights y'all guys
yeah bring it baby
but if you're ready for the smallest
we've got you covered
that are nothing like this one
and go solo
[Music]
now they're gonna talk about grounded oh
my god out of city we're dedicated to
pushing narrative and role-playing games
it's something we do every day when we
come to the office and we can't wait for
you to play our next great adventure
parallel on gorgon it's the first of two
planned story expansion packs for the
outer world that we're putting together
with our friends from the private
division now it's also important that we
continue to evolve how we tell stories
in games and grounded is the perfect
example of that the team has been
working for the last two years on how to
tell an obsidian story within a survival
game now what's great is that you're
going to be able to play the game on
july 28th on xbox game preview and on
steam early access we want to hear from
you and we want to continue to build
grounded together oh yeah if you've been
wondering we have been working on that
next big obsidian rpg you see that check
this out oh here we go okay
world premiere better not be grounded
too
let's get it oh here we go
they're rpg
this is what happens when they let them
get their bars off we have always known
wars
[Music]
this is very weird
it looks very lordly
this definitely looks skyrim there's a
dragon that shows up right here
it forged our empire
turned heroes into queens and kings
and decimated our foes
[Music]
now our oaths are lost
forsaken
[Music]
remember remember
[Music]
that was it right there when he did the
symbol what's wrong with you wow
christopher where's the game play
a vowed is an expansive first-person rpg
set in the fantasy world of eora
when obsidian entertainment joined xbox
game studios they told us that this epic
game is the one they want to make
critically yeah rpgs this is obsidian at
their best and it is being built
you're taking a different advantage
we also work with independent developers
[Music]
i'm excited to announce
that they don't even know when they're
getting a new studio led by some of the
most talented storytellers
let's meet caroline marshall studio head
interior night to debut their original
game
what they said another game
yes what is the same one
i'm counting from
about interactive storytelling because
when you play your story you step into
the character's shoes
you get your experience their fears
their hopes their conflicts first hand
and in the process you learn more about
yourself
and this is quite powerful
our first game spans 30 years in the
american southwest
it's a story about family
people trying to find their way in a
world that don't fit in
i hope you enjoy the trailer
world premiere
everything has been a whirlwind
yeah for our family it was just to stop
over
oh i was about to say
[Music]
i was about to say i wasn't
taking it too far now
you're just the end of the road
i'm like these people looking real
[Music]
coincidence
[Music]
no
it was a long forgotten secret
buried in the dark
i'll tell you right now if you're
playing like that
all my life i've been scared of the
shadows
it's just it i mean it's one of those
interactive sort of i'm finally ready to
kind of tell talish but it doesn't seem
like a i just want to know if this one's
images
it seems like it's going to be the
stiffness
here at ninja theory we're hard at work
on all of our
an incredible 3.5 million players have
now experienced senua's story and
hellblade center was sacramento
we're excited to start giving you an
insight into what comes next for our
celtic warrior an experience that we'll
be building in unreal engineering that's
60 frames per second definitely uh
very different
i'm happy to reveal today that cena was
saga will be set in the amazing
mouth of iceland
and you can find out more about our
location scouting and how we've
discovered the history of our setting in
a brand new behind the scenes
development diary which you can view
straight after the show on the ninja
theory youtube channel
go to the channel later it's been so
touching to see the impact that
hellblade central sacrifice has had on
so many players
and we're incredibly thankful to all of
these fans that have been hurt
we're excited for you to be part of art
from here on out
come on
oh damn i want to see wow
wow
same energy here we go okay
i ain't gonna lie man
it's starting to go downhill man i don't
know what this is
but this definitely up here with bug
snacks double fine oh okay
do you wanna say hi to peter okay okay
peter peter he's been sitting there the
whole time
he wrote the song let's get to it
oh all right jack black all right
fantastic work love the song
very much it's gonna be fun to sing it
now it's time to to rock
shall we start rocking
this is your king ha ha yo blaze you
stupid
well you already know what this game is
this is equal not right what is this
don't watch this show gameplay for this
though
the same way that y'all got gameplay for
um
what was that timing crisis game yeah
what's up the game that they had
writing baby
they gave a date
[Music]
i lost connection i couldn't repeat uh
[Music]
money
[Music]
hell yeah
a second
[Music]
[Applause]
they show the new obsidian game
i just i'm a little disappointed
they literally just said yo we're doing
it in iceland yeah
[Music]
2.
but you got to pay for it and you're
going to pay for it because that's what
you do
he was hoping
to magic
oh you know what this is this is going
directly at uh sony baby
way too long on this cycle give it a lot
of pause
look at me what is it though
i look downhill right now i'm sorry
y'all look home like that you started
off
i thought this sony showed we saw a
couple of looks again
that's fine but look at this
people are super excited
longer
you know how many people have been
looking for this game to come out
so yeah my six-year-old son
well he'd be able to play it
you got game pass right of course i do
from the largest publishers to the
smallest independent developers to bring
you the broadest variety of games oh
here we go
there is one developer in particular
that is close to us not just
geographically but in history too
destiny thrilled to announce that this
fall our friends at bungie will bring
destiny 2 to xbox series x look at the
ray tracer's shoulders
it's gameplay put your knees down
this is all i care about
yes destiny 2 yes unplayable
come home from the cloud bungie come
home later
we still got your room
they got the marketing oh we got the
marketing let's go
um
[Music]
yes
i'm in fix your face aim fix your face
oh man
we use the stasis powers we got the
darkness
let's go
[Music]
now
all right
they knocked out the puck
10 out of 10 shows
knocked it out the park
last word will be lit this friday
these are these are their uh console
launch exclusive games
oh man
this looks crazy
i hope it's medium
boy that's blueberry uber
it's blue but blueberry is a medium but
i'm buying some hell fun it could be
compulsion
[Music]
no launch console launch exclusive is
not controlled
this is a will me hood game
oh this is definitely
this is spooky
[Music]
don't know what this is it looks like
some stranger things something yeah like
this
is it
what is this
is it medium
stalker 2
oh wow
that's that's on species
it's going to say gay pass i might try
to
console launch exclusive oh earl
premiere here we go
let me go with these names
oh my backwards
yeah i know
the backlog
the hell see they went dog they like
crazy they were dark oh you guys we
don't talking all that kitty stuff
[Music]
up this gives me like a dishonest
our recon squad has been sent into sub
level six of the hive or hammer
blazes
i'll know more yo more hammer bro
oh
edwards with the two dollar super chat
so we can cross play d2 on xbox pcb next
year next year first is going to be all
xbox consoles bungie said and then next
year they're doing the full cross play
with playstation and pc
yeah us first them later
wait wait
[Music]
so playstation four and five xbox one in
the series
yeah us first y'all later
bungie dumped
[Music]
kiss
[Music]
those are all the people that's actually
going to have fun this holiday season
with the games
all the people that bought xbox this
whole generation
oh my god this is all it's tetris damn
it man
tetris
[Music]
is this the battle royal tetris
let's go attic you gotta do it now
you gotta take that out
no no
no
no
no
no
let's go let's tell them nothing we're
adding
you making baby
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yo this could not happen worse
put it in tetris
oh this is steam world heights
it feels like
oh
this is what's up i'm all in for the
sucking of blackness
all i know is they better end this with
fable
this is fable
i think they're going to end it with
flames mabel legends too i think this is
favorite oh my god ain't showing up open
world do that we got i got faith
your man said open whoa
is gonna be here yeah yeah
i didn't know that's a good pass
yeah this is probably medium
yeah
he doesn't like medium i like his
favorite he's pretty beautiful
oh here's the word
[Music]
in between worlds at the same time as
nuts
scent of pines
and then
the gunshots
yeah they're not playing every story
but you can probably like slip in and
out of time
the worlds are supposed to change right
in front of you
yeah but also a darker and deeper you
get like an allen weight box
i said that the first time i saw it
i can see better and i don't i don't
know i want to see more of it because i
i get alan wake and silent hill like
mixed yeah and actually the the guys
that did the uh soundtrack for silent
hill are doing the one for this game
like okay so
when she's in another reality gameplay
two worlds rendered simultaneously
oh that's like that game uh
yo
yo
simultaneously i'm gonna eat myself just
for a second while i scream
i okay it looks
it looks crazy two worlds render time
they look crazy that looks crazy that
render that ps2 graph oh man
playstation 2 graphics
120 and they sleep for no reason
they still got that was the phrase world
premiere very good that looks crazy so
this ain't console yeah let me keep
saying game pass
gameplay
expect these can we expect these at
launch what does that mean
they just mean at launch it's going to
be on the xbox one yeah but if they got
a one
year deal i would assume
this would have been better if it was
personal
oh okay
what's this
fantasy
the game we already knew about
yeah
and it's disgusting we lose it
i tried to play this game it's just not
me
[Music]
must be playing this game although they
played this all day
yeah
listen game for service worked well in
game pass
and this suit never looked better
yeah that suit never looked better
but it's just i don't know i fell out of
it after i stopped playing on my own my
dreamcast was it dream favorite problem
just doing cash yeah yeah i stopped
playing enough to that but i used to
play hours on end with it yeah yeah and
get addicting for sure
[Music]
hey maddie you're disappointed i feel
like the show is okay
[Music]
think it's solid two but we need
favorites
it's a very solid they got it
[Music]
it's it's a very stylish so this game
frame rate looks spooky right there
it fits a lot of people's uh watch them
before they still got now i thought the
series x could handle that though
i'm joking
come over yo come over again
because i said laugh out loud the
world's most powerful
[Music]
what is
oh this is crossfire it's the campaign
[Music]
absolutely
because this
if
that 120 is weird that like that that
looks cute
yo yo if it was 120 though king they
were saying you know i mean they would
definitely fly
well well i'm gonna tell you right now
this is this is 60.
yo
it looks
sick like this is my second most like
game after haters oh i'm definitely
gonna win whenever i completely
call rev up he might be in on this oh
red definitely by being on this one
but i'm definitely
this is just a peek at some of the new
titles coming to xbox series x and some
of the games you already love and some
you have better than this
will also be optimized for xbox series x
games like i better have that we have
one more game for you gears five i ain't
even staying for the pre-show man i
leave right after this gen upgrades and
no additional costs
of verizon looks crazy you can expect a
lineup of over 100 titles for xbox
series x this holiday season with series
x and game pass
xbox is the place to play
and you
are at the center of everything we do
now you may have noticed we didn't get
to visit all of our xbox game studios
today that means we'll have more to
share later this year but until then
here's one more thank you oh jesus
christ thank you premiere oh my god man
i was literally scared there for a
second watching should not be fable
watch your [ __ ] not be favorable have
faith that's going on
it's fable baby i feel it
playing let's go
oh yo i'm
yo that's fable
oh no definitely favorite
wondrous place
oh
[Music]
[Music]
that's right christopher hardy i knew
there was going to be no gameplay for
this fight
you're good you're good
you're good
[Music]
oh my god
that tetris
literally blew me away
did you put on a touch with it did you
tell us your stand out you know what
really
why it blew me away for the simple fact
for no reason
it was like it's like he heard us it was
like you'll put that text in there
i think ted was bleeding away in 84
i do think microsoft's got the marking
to deal with uh destiny and netflix
[Music]
he didn't attain that it really is today
like i said he has the people in price
what was your favorite game
i wanted to chat with your favorite
games
so there's not many games
and all these [ __ ] i'm in the game
pass
literally out of 10 jdl okay okay
watch it now where they doing they still
stay here
all these good game pass
[Music]
are we doing the post show like
going back to google hangouts well hold
on isn't there an official post show
from microsoft
i'm with jeff keagley right now yeah
okay
[Music]
what is it summer game whatever
yeah
there we go
posted a poll on twitter how would you
grade xbox in the press conference and
what they did uh we want to hear your
opinion on it and what xbox showed
across their entire portfolio one
interesting thing everything they would
have definitely got an xbox game pass
but they have two consoles
you know it's pretty impressive that all
those titles are gonna want xbox one
how did xbox do in the main show well
let's welcome them back again we've got
jd
fresh off the live show okay we were all
watching it so christopher hart i've
done a lot of talking
uh let's
this is probably going to be another
hour long yeah that show is going to be
like conference itself you want to go
and just kick it out
the pre-show where you announced that
that's funny
all righty
all righty we got that live in direct
what go on people
you know
let's get it man let's start with the
kick first cuz uh i gotta get the keg in
here and then we're gonna go with the
guests we gotta start the king first man
what are we thinking
okay well like i said um i give it a
solid eight
um
and let me let me tell you how i scored
the the sony show right because it is
inevitably gonna be compared to each
other right because that's how it goes
i'm not worrying about the pre-show the
pre-show um sony didn't have a pre-show
so microsoft wins the pre-show period
all right so now we and and sony didn't
have a may show they just had day shows
so microsoft has uh two shows ahead of
them right so you can compare show again
show
um bar for bar
microsoft beat them on every turn ball
for bar right
but i felt that uh and
the only reason why is uh sony doesn't
have a service for me to try every game
that i've seen there if even if i'm
intrigued about a game
i can't say i'm going to touch because i
can't because i'm not spending no money
on it i'm not in this day and age i'm
not gonna front like i got money to be
burning on something that i'm not gonna
play right so that's that's neither here
nor there no every game i saw here
even if i felt like that gunk game y'all
y'all may think i'm joking
but i saw it and said wow it looks
amazing
i can give it a try right if i don't
like it i don't have to go back to it i
can uninstall it and go to something
else that's good so obsidian uh they
showed more stuff for me
they'll find i'm definitely into the
psychonauts too
uh you sort of uh i like the forza
going back to its essence i like halo
look like it's going back to their
essence
so maybe fable will go back to their
essence like they're getting
to uh grounded right no pun intended
a grounded level where
everything is going back to what made it
great again so
i give it a solid eight i can't give it
a 10
because there was some lows in the
minute like it was a little bit lost in
the middle yeah like like life is
strange you know that's not for me right
then there's other people that played
life is strange and they and they're
just jumping around right and your joke
yeah i think i'm joking with the tetris
but
he was going hard for the tetris he's
going hard you know why
because no no no list that i had had
tetris on it now one list had tetris on
it and that was in complete shock i like
being shocked so when i was born you
were blown away by the
no you know why it is
played tetris before it was like a
single oh in the corner so game pass
multiplayer the world
okay yeah so i was always like if i'm
going to to go pay the phone bill for my
mother i got my game boy in my hand and
i'm sitting and playing tetris
by myself i'll tell you now
this opens it up i can play tetris
against somebody you know and battle
them i don't know it just opens the
doors up for you so move that's going to
move yeah
there's no doubt so give me give me what
happened
your
what was the joy that gave wowed you
what was your joy on the show that what
are the moments of the show that halo
yeah okay that is
if you walked away anything from uh from
this show it's halo you already know
forza is going to
that forza looked amazing
right but halo
that was the wolf it looked otherworldly
it just
i'm sorry but
and that's what i'm going to play i'm
going to play that this year mm-hmm i'm
a ready ant i'm i'm finished i'm done
question for k before i get it
was it worth the wait the entire show
yes
okay you know you know what um
excuse me sorry
they
fixed
anything that they had a problem with in
me
okay
the transitions was clean they did now
it's on um they did just announce on
xbox i mean we pretty much knew that
fabe was going to be a series x
exclusive oh it's not coming to the base
it's not coming to the base
all right they're going to desire lords
i don't want to hear that
and then i know as we don't hear that so
there's probably two three years out
it's like two years
yes sir i'm right here you got the major
nelson thing going on so i want to i
want to get you in first after that um i
need your thoughts brother like where
you at with the show give me your rating
and just overall feel and then you stand
out
well i mean look look there there's a
lot to take away from the show now i
understand that when we as fans
we have these mega lists that we put out
perfect dark was gonna be there batman
was going to be there all these people
again would be look look i'm going to
tell you this right now
the one that the the one show stopper
that needed
to show its face
was halo
and they started the conference off with
that
and showed us game play they showed us
cut scenes it transitioned from
literally watching a movie to playing a
movie
and that's hard to do and they figured a
way to do it uh first and foremost
before you even get to the games aspect
the presentation
was on a level i did not know they could
do shout out to the high quality stream
it is
unbelievable
again compared to some of the things
they've done before yes this was
a plus quality
the transitions the speed on how fast
they got from game to game to game sure
there were a couple of lows with some of
the smaller titles that a lot of people
don't really care for and that's fine
right but the but the exclamation point
before we get into that my opinion on
the show and and giving it a rating it's
the fact that and i have to go to k with
king with this every game here
is game pass that was big the magic i
would say like 80 percent it felt like
they showed over i think it's like 20 or
20 i think it's 22 23 games
and it could be more and and and i'm not
counting the pre-show
and every one of those games are going
in there they're going into game pair so
you can play these games for your game
pass subscription save the k3 whoa
yeah that was for me
i didn't think that was coming
it looked great forza what do you expect
it's it's going to be running at 120
frames per second
and ori you can say what you want about
grounded you can say what you want about
all we know about outer worlds they show
the new dlc yes but the fact that we got
confirmation of what avowed looked like
triple a yeah was that not a win that
was big that was big yes i agree that is
the first
aaa rpg made by the masters
of rpg making facts
looking like they're doing skyrim better
than oh i go too far but they skyrim bag
and and you have some other ones in
there you know as dusk falls was
extremely interesting
right you know you also had okay we
didn't get help with game play now i'm
not going to sit here in front and say
that i wasn't slightly disappointed yeah
you know
it was
more than
you know like a reveal i agree but you
have to look at some of the other stuff
first of all that crossfire x oh that's
crazy
folks that's that's an exclusive to
microsoft that's not coming to anyone
else that is on their console and that's
being made by remedy right huge do you
know what i'm saying huge deal so and
again
filter in the other games maybe they're
not for you maybe tell me why isn't for
you i hear you right but like king said
it is for an audience right that loves
that that loves um don't not right and
then of course
the absolute again not we didn't get
confirmation uh
you know for game play
but we got the confirmation that we've
all been asking for for years and
playground games is making fables i just
had you open you opened up with a banger
you closed with the banger and you know
something at the end of the day i have
to walk away
with the b plus i got to give it an 8.5
out of 10. i think that they did enough
for me
as an xbox fan to say yes we have stuff
coming and here's the other thing the
matte booty
tells me that the august show could
potentially produce
many of the game of the studios that
were not there he said oh he said it he
actually said
we're not sure from all of our studios
right now we're going to show from from
later i was surprised they said that and
give you a more credible
kudos to the one more thing for the
first time from xbox yes because that's
what i think was big because that is
i know what he probably feels about
certain i'm very curious about that but
i have to give them the props that that
is something we've always wanted and
they finally did that so overall 8.5
your number one standout
of the show
halo halo infinite for sure
they started they they started with it
and i'm going to end with it it is
we as someone who's been extremely
critical publicly and privately about
halo 5.
not the gameplay right not the graphics
right the story right what they have
done for me as a as a long time halo fan
someone that has been here since og days
they have gotten me interested in a way
from master chief
listen the game looks like nothing we've
played before and again i have to just
keep hearkening back to that transition
it went from movie to game yes good
point unbelievable point good point
you're absolutely right
the frame rate was very silky
even i mean listen you could see
the detail in some of the elites armor
you can see the grappling hook hello
welcome nice you know panic grabbing the
box
again this show may not be for everyone
and i can guarantee you there are going
to be the trolls of the internet that
hate this
but if you hate this then you're just
not a gamer
right now and that's i'm going to stand
strong in that savings square if you
hated this show
fix your face
and go play some basketball or something
all right boom boom landed down right
ahead of major dozen real quick we get
these super chats real quick midway
monster with the 5 super chat no longer
need to justify value of game pass now
in my opinion wow so good pass
definitely move them hold on every game
there is in game play pretty pretty much
man um then we had let me see
shout out to philly eagle i told y'all
last week this show was very diverse no
show is perfect 9 out of 10 for me so
many games i'm excited for jd you want
to take the rest of us off i got jd
gamer super chat fanny star online new
genesis yes is a new game right
it says
online two new genesis new genesis i
don't know yeah so it's building an
expansion or something yeah it seems
like an expansion
so uh saying tomlin with the five pound
super chat phil aurelius spencer don't
argue the king
k3 looks absolutely amazing
it's just cgi but the fact that the
animals the animals
where they're going with it
i just i want it to look great and run i
think it will
think because remember anytime that they
showed that that game they they showed
it looking rudimentary before right even
in the trailers
and
this this trailer looked different and
looked just like i think i budget yeah
and i got budget i go for it
smith with the two dollar super chat
tell him boom no let me get clowns shout
out to clowns four guys recorded five
seconds oh my god king david has been
hired to collect those knees on the
fable naysayers i told everyone fable
fable fable favor
he going in man it's a living for the
favorite guys i have faith but you know
let me transition right on into that
right because hold on we got oh we still
james oh yeah we got ak bet it's finest
with the fight jump hold on a second uh
listen that medium and forza eight lord
next level
i don't think it's fours or eight i
think it's they might be rebooting yeah
just as blue forza motorsport announced
yeah yeah it falls on motorsport i think
it's just straight up and then we got
james 176 two dollar super chat destiny
two coming the game
game was over
we got bounty boom with the five dollar
super chat hold on my god oh well halo
oh my god it looks like i'm playing halo
for the first time wow
wow congratulations brother yeah
you know what let me just if you guys
don't mind i
i have to run i know that's why i wanted
you first so i want to just say this
first of all gentlemen it was a pleasure
to hang out with everyone thank you so
much for having me on
two important points of contention one
the larry herb interview let's go i'm
sitting down with him at 3 30. okay
y'all yeah so so no actually don't
because it's covered yeah yeah what's
going to happen is i'm doing it private
it's going to be privately done
and it's it's it's a true one-on-one
and
as soon as that is done and i check the
audio levels and i make sure everything
is proper i'm going to upload it to my
youtube channel so if you have
notifications on you're going to know
i'm going to put i'm going to put out
some advertisement for and i believe
microsoft is going to be doing that as
well a microsoft is going to be helping
me uh push the channel which is
ridiculous but they're gonna yeah
they're gonna push the interview with
larry
and uh and eight o'clock and eight
o'clock tonight
uh we are going to have uh the uh post
show on my channel
the panel is massive and there's gonna
be a lot of big opinions and i hope
everyone could come back absolutely and
uh and finish off your evening and your
celebration with uh with what we got to
say double barrel gaming boom brother
i'm so excited congratulations that's so
big brother major nelson he's got the
interview he's going to go up on the
channel rock out my boy man he's been
putting it down for a long time one of
the most positive people in the
community always helps everybody out
doesn't think about anybody else and now
to see you get these rewards man these
are your blessings brother
i appreciate it yeah thank you so much
well listen
enjoy the rest of your day and enjoy
enjoy enjoy being an xbox gamer there's
a lot to be excited about and like i
said the hate is going to come but it's
it's you know what don't pay no
attention to it because quite frankly
there is a lot of games coming and we
gotta we saw a lot today no doubt boom
killer brother
is always your friend
no doubt though
all right guys thank you let's get these
super chances and i want to get into
attic of the guests we got
cat daddy with the fly last super chat
just popped in and say attic was right
bend the knee and bend
yeah you what
i'm here for the game past diversity
halo fable stated the k3 got me hyped
everything isn't for everyone but
there's no way you didn't come from this
show with something you enjoy
nine out of ten with the question mark
for king aurelius
no
okay oh i don't know
i respect that okay yeah remember i told
you the the aurelius comes after he
undercuts sony for the price and
um and boxes them in that's that's it oh
you know um
i did put it out of reach at some point
for him but um this is this is the way
he can obtain it um the playstation
launches at 500 what up whatever the
price is you got to come in cheaper and
either launch uh date and day or you
know before or whatever but just box
them in and just don't make it make it
hard for them to breathe you already
made them hard for them to breed with
game pass everything you've seen is in
game pass so
they're choking on that no doubt shout
out to jd gamer files with chat don't
sleep on dragons quest facts the fact
that there are multiple square games
means that those sony ropes are
loosening up microsoft has dropped the
back
he may be on to something
you really order something man we got to
see look at i need you
this was a very important show for you
and
to stay a lot a lot of pony contracts
were waiting for you if if if this
didn't go the way you want it so uh i
need your feelings bro like where are
you at
i want to get just their bounty boom
with the 5 super chat i meant to say it
looks like when you're playing halo for
the very first time that's how good it
looks
and we have gamers play with the final
super cat i told everyone xbox is coming
for the throw dragon quest a new sc game
something wonder world crossfire x cam
book of x
book of exile here did they have pixel
bit g what yeah
halo y'all peep what's tack map and
upgrades
oh yeah solid state of the crate three
yes a vow the gunk 8.5 for me but man
that stream was not holding it down
check the 4k vod
yeah
fair enough fair enough all right we got
to get it back to attic man like where
you at with this man overall
show your feeling about the show i have
to give it a 9 out of 10.
i thought you was disappointed you
didn't sound good
i had to take the one for the wack stuff
that they re-showed us again but
like you know at the end of the day they
showed us they showed us that
um obsidian is making a new rpg they
showed us fable they showed us halo
which i'm looking at twitter a lot of
people don't seem to like what they saw
in halo which i don't get that
i literally saw someone said i wanted to
see more what more could they have
showed you besides the actual damn game
like they they but we're not getting
into that they show plenty of stuff
that's coming uh as a launch exclusive
you know sure did they show stuff that i
didn't care about yes but you know they
what i i would have preferred not
grounded not to been there at all but
that's besides the fact
but you know they showed every while
that they showed what they showed is
that xbox has games coming yes
and
and that's what we really wanted like
they did show some stuff i didn't care
about
but it's just like at the end of the day
like
i
if if i compare this on its own maybe it
would be a little lower i'm kind of
comparing it to its competition you know
but compared to what sony showed last
month i think it's hitting out of the
park the same people that are
complaining about what they showed today
are the same people saying that sony
showed a hit out of the park conference
and it's just like look
they showed us games that they're making
yes
like and what's funny is the same people
they're saying the pacing was the same
people that whole middle section of
sony's was trash like
it's like look i i i got it maybe maybe
if i i might go to eight because there
was a there wasn't a lot of gameplay but
to be honest with you i was i was
prepared for that why
was it a nine for you nine is high i
didn't your energy was a little during
the show you were you were kind of p you
started
i told you all they had to show me was
halo a good direction of halo and faith
look i told i'm i'm attic world i'm
gonna shout you back
i'm going to clip that because it was so
epic and then i'm like i told you
i probably do want to go down at eight
because of the gameplay but yeah it's
like look at the end of the day i
expected that for microsoft i got to
watch the show they still don't have
enough time to show us like definitive
slice gameplay if you look at it from
sony sony didn't show us anything on
games that should have gameplay we saw
ratchet and clank we didn't see demon
souls how long has that game been in
development no gameplay horizon that
game's supposed to come out next year no
gameplay like i expected more gameplay
from them because those games were in
development longer than these games i
knew there weren't going to be no
favorable gameplay i knew there was
going to be no obsidian gameplay we just
needed to know these games are coming
out i feel that i feel i've been
impressed with that wow this has been
big uh big blades man i got to keep this
fair now all right let's get this oh get
the super chat then we go get blaze get
the super chat
to find out chat show is the nine
because no longer people can say halo
gears forza they're
and i do want to point out that i see
people saying that there's not going to
be a dark grainy
on fable i took that that trailer a
completely different way they started it
we started off nicely nice
literally the new fable killing the old
fable
as a fact that that's the part that got
me too so what else we call who goes
what's that from rare jayhard007
to be honest
it was he said be honest it was trash
addict
i mean look at at the end they look i'll
go down to eight but that's that's as
low as i would ever go because it
doesn't it doesn't deserve anything
lower than eight they showed you why you
should buy series x sure some of the
games not appeal to you but it they show
that they're a diverse console they show
that they're going to like yo we
understand you guys ain't feeling how we
don't we don't mess with japanese games
that much we got dragon quest they
started off with they so so it's just
like well at the end of the day am i
disappointed with them re-showing stuff
of course
but it's just like i can't sit here and
act like they didn't show us a new rpg
from fro from obsidian probably one of
the best rpg makers out right now they
showed a new expansion from outer world
probably one of the best rpgs that's out
right now they showed fable they they
show you know i was extremely
disappointed with no bleeding edge which
i don't care about bleeding edge anyway
so we're gonna move past that but you
know they showed what i wanted and
everyone in the chat they might have
showed they might not have showed what
you wanted but guess what i'm not you
you're good you're good you got the bag
you got your you good you got halo first
you got your prediction the way you what
are you doing
you're good and the dizzy i was right
yeah you got better these this guy
actually got a bet that need to shout
out to easily he got a better deed to
you you guys went at me hard
hard for you
and i just sat there because i knew you
were wrong
because i knew you were wrong
i was going to hell no your argument
wasn't what why it was just it was hell
what was your argument like
but they
what's funny is they went the way i said
they should have went because they knew
if they didn't it wasn't that it was
actually
the addict's world for being petty
my money just got longer with game pass
my series x my new lg c10
with plenty of money left over to buy a
seagate game
that king talk right there
talking that's what i'm talking about jd
gaming follow-up super chat halo fable
forza everywhere destiny and game pass
medium crossfire x campaign and a vow
look amazing now where the ponies at i
want me oh
you're talking spicy you talking spicy
look at y'all good job jonathan b with
the possum chat attic was shaky towards
the end i agree i thought alex was
shaking he gave me that
we
you know they showed me something really
good at the beginning but like i don't
understand why fable wasn't at the end
eight
six out of ten that's what six out of
three right what's two points
yo shout out to me
wow that's my point everyone look crispy
lord [ __ ] we getting 60 frames with
jessie nova bomb straight fire baby
ain't nobody no ain't nobody in this
panel playing that game no i've been on
for a while
i'm in on that oh you said
everything they showed there because
it's gonna be in game pass except for
that strange thing thing hey life is
strange let's go let's go look man um
blaze are we back sir playstation nation
are you unmuted or you step away damn i
want to blaze if not that's all good
will be you back i know wilmington he's
on a phone call we got two that must've
stepped away quickly oh i'm back okay
there we go all right so lord will me
hood gaming beyond the box
what did you feel about this show sir
i'm giving this show a nine out of ten
all day wow
yeah most of those games is for him yeah
a lot of hearts oh yeah
stalker 2 medium halo and of course
fable
uh man there's just my backlog just
keeps getting bigger and bigger
and
i mean mainly i play pc
and i saw a lot of games on there that
are running 60.
so that makes me happy
by itself and i'm not running one of
these i'm going to pull a king on
everybody
i'm not playing a cyber power or i power
pc
i am on a 7 000
custom build origin
flexo
yeah i'm not and i just don't have a tcl
monitor
you play into the how would go kick you
playing to the limit what does it say
he's he's gaming at the high at the
highest exactly
yes yes but to me this show it it was
diverse there's a lot of games people
wanted the
based games like not about that good
point yeah people like me there's a
little bit of everything in this show
and they did say that's not everything
yeah yeah
yeah so i do believe a lot of this
because there's already rumors there's
going to be a marketing show for sony
next month yes
i think a lot of this
is going to come back
as a
how did saul said a couple weeks ago i
think xbox is going to come back to put
the boot on the neck
with their next show
that's when i think you'll see a couple
of the other ips that we're missing
but fable oh my god
uh i had to mute myself man because i
was screaming like a little smoother
you had another game you wanted to mute
yourself too you were going crazy it was
like a what what game medium it was a
medium right yeah
with the
dual realities right at this point
oh man that that is going to be
unbelievable that crossfire
i mean you you can't go wrong with
remedy
any time so the
lord of horror was pleased
oh i am very big and i cannot wait
the dog give me so
ultimate standout obviously what was it
what was the thing that made you
the most hype if you could pick one
oh it'd be halo oh
man i've played all the halo games
you know back you know in the days we
used to land parties
i've played every halo game there's ever
been since launch so for me master chief
oh yeah and then you're happy munchie's
coming home you know where to get to
boston you already know what i'm getting
so it's over again the show's over
already it was i mean everybody
installed destiny now
gabe i got no excuse to join me now
and that's another thing man game pass i
mean the numbers came out yesterday
you know because everybody you know in
the chat loves to throw around numbers
and all this and how much money did did
they show yesterday their their services
went up 64 percent
yeah
i mean this this isn't a joke this isn't
you know fanboy fodder anymore no this
is this is proven that's a fact and game
pass today became more legit than it has
ever been definitely definitely
definitely validated that man let me get
a super chat before and then i'll get
into blaze and if uh which extreme is
back and then we got def but philly
eagle follow us with a chat if you came
here solely to hate on games throw
yourself in the bushes gamers are
winning next gen fanboys jump off a
bridge figuratively yeah i'm like damn
really you're trying to kill me it's
hard to jump off a bridge at 30 fps
did you get hey
please please check hello baby
dead
never i need some knees no doubt mike we
got michael b
not okay
did we get that one you know we got
that's that's next year michael b 10
super chat not all games are the same i
play pc because i because i sim race
have 28k invested in my rig and pc damn
yeah i appreciate game pass for what it
is for peeps like like me that don't
feel like paying 60 dollars for a game
i'll get
i'll get an a
i get an s oh okay an s and that's no
doubt shout out to that
i'm blind today i can't say that
y'all gotta give addict his knees
regarding halo starting the show he
gotta pay off those high interest rate
knees he took a loan
[Laughter]
shout out to shroom bms oh get oh get
stitched for me
with the 2000 with christopher heart at
christopher
was set in the same world yes as pillars
of eternity that's what got me excited
yes um we got boogie man fought out of
super chat the medium is up for
pre-order on xbox right now what
what
50 no date
no doubt no doubt no doubt
nope we got jd gaming with the final
super cat uh microsoft out here putting
ponies eyes on tape
where they see any gameplay i say nah
you blind baby
give me
get that one card yeah the show was a
solid 9 out of 10 just for the fact they
showed lots of game almost for everyone
avowed fable stated dedicated to halo
everwow let's go
no doubt stated the k3 man that that was
just that that looks amazing
yeah i mean it was yeah it was cgi but
the fact like i said like the fact that
animals are going to be a direction
yes yeah yeah i got it
and then we got peptides
on god in them state of decay 3 i'm
ready yo everybody
so we are we finally caught up because i
got to get these other guys there jd
gamer once again
chat
medium was doing uh with the mature
title what sony's super fast ssd
couldn't do with
carpeting ratchet and clank
velocity architecture wow let's see
are we good now we're caught up all
right
blazing uh scream who's here
i'm here all right scream is bad okay so
scream you never left yeah i just never
asked jordan yeah scream what's up
brother you know we we've been talking a
lot you know i had to get your opinion
you so everybody said no wilhelm scream
is one of the best destiny content
creators
out here he doesn't get enough he
doesn't like to retweet his own stuff so
we're going to promote him out here in
the realm of the lords but that's my
homie give me your impression of as a pc
gamer primarily you know
what you felt about this show
um well i
played a lot of halo like halo was like
my
number one game probably through college
wow
i even went to one of the mlg
tournaments once wow talk about talk so
for me that was the thing i was um
looking forward to seeing the most
it looks really really cool i mean the
that transition was there was some stuff
about it that was very subtle but i
think
obviously the 60 frames per second
i just kind of knew it was going to look
really good i knew it was going to be
the best looking halo
stylistically it looks like they kind of
went a little old school with it which i
kind of like
um
so for me the multiplayer is always
what's really important yeah which is
probably what i'll look at the most but
as far as a like
sort of from what i got the gameplay
impression of that was
kind of classic halo 1 sort of mode yes
so that was really cool forza looked
really cool uh congratulations to attic
for like hitting it at the park with
like get like the triple double today or
whatever yes you got a triple double
today facts thanks
that was cool yes um
even though i'm not a big fan i've never
played fabled but it was kind of cool to
see it on there and um
yeah what was that other game that was
the beginning one it was an fps it was
like uh
something with mechs
oh i forgot about that in the pre-show
yeah that was yeah that transformers and
the the robots
looking robot and what i got from that
was like if the multiplayer for halo
looks at least that good oh it will bro
the same thing scream i said if halo
both i'm playing like that
i feel like they did that almost as like
uh
we're not going to show you the other
thing that you really want today but
this is kind of close yes i forgot about
that gabe good call yes and um
what was um the other
what was the other multiplayer that i
was thinking of that looked really good
multiplayer what was this style game if
you could remember i think it was an fps
but i'm trying to remember what it was
was it the
crossfire no that wasn't oh oh well
destiny coming over that's kind of about
to sing like
what
what's going on screen how you felt
about this i know i
think the thing that i do i forget about
uh yeah that looks really fun and they
premiere i think they premiered some of
those abilities
that looks really neat like the whole
climbing aspect that they were using
like throwing stuff on the wall that's
gonna get i'm gonna have so much fun
doing stuff with that i know there's
gonna be like
like workarounds galore for that kind of
glitchy stuff but then um what was that
one game that it kind of had a weird
name that was and that's the last thing
i'll i'll really say it was it kind of
just
the name was it was like gonk or
something like that oh the gunk
the gun the gun
yeah
just kind of a weird name very
off-putting very off-putting name today
i think uh yeah is that anything else
you guys need me for um if what was
gonna wrap
up
yeah i'm being summoned all right you're
being sobbing go go ahead with your
business
but i want disney salute to your fable
you got your wish
good show for you you're good i already
know you could continue um so yeah and
that was the last one you said scream as
far as the other right yeah and that's i
mean those are the things that kind of
stood out to me but overall like i'd
give it at least an eight out of ten oh
you know but i expected at least i i you
know i thought it was going to be a good
show no doubt no doubt it doesn't take
much to impress me
don't take much what you had to so the
single most moment
was it halo for you
yeah just to get to see anything with
halo was really what i was looking
forward to and just kind of i mean we
didn't get i don't think too much but
between that and that other first person
shooter that we saw
being played i i kind of get a good
feeling about where they're going to go
i hope they do
like a broader gaming experience with it
where it is like we get to see where we
want to go and we can just go there and
maybe
some sort of
even make a battle royale played into it
i don't know if it's just going to be
what we saw in like an
arena type multiplayer but
fair enough
foreign to get blaze and
get uh death singer and definitely still
here then we got master clown
watching the show with the lords was
godfire oh
low key the gunk look graphically better
than ratchet and clay
that's five like the variety of the show
as a whole shout out to noobsidebot okay
okay
look man death man you you you waved the
xbox flag kind of high so it's like you
were quiet during the show but i know a
lot of people were here so you probably
could get all your bars off well no no
no i was muted off with the shirt and i
didn't even realize oh i'm like yo
where's deb
i'm used to your hype level i don't hear
it i'm like is he disappointed i was
muted no
i was hyped uk what's up baby to talk to
me man where you at all right all right
wait a minute
then
i'll initially start with the pacing was
good that is really good pacing that's
what we needed yeah
the lack of gameplay does take it down a
notch because the outside of halo there
was pretty much none
um
now as for what they showed me yes there
is a lot of games i got an entire list
really oh yeah
let's get it
all right so
according to my list the game still
really stuck out to me halo infinite
that looks fire that that that's halo's
back
now state state k3 oh i'm a huge fan
and i always said stair decay 2 if it
had a budget it'd be so much better
now they have a budget and it looks like
they have a better engine so i'm on fire
and there's zombie creature animals name
okay cool cool
there we have forza motorsport of course
big forza fan so
and it's a reboot so hey go for it i
mean they decided to reboot it which
makes sense with a brand new engine
shame they didn't show gameplay because
normally forza does have
gameplay ever
ever wild
from the initial reveal they did i was
kind of like is this gonna be all right
but
now they've shown a lot of it oh granted
what gameplay but it looks interesting
it looks like a pixar
movie and you could just
look single player it's back to you know
it's none of that sea of thieves
they got it back on track and rear is
looking good
then i have
they tell me why it looks good but it's
definitely not for me that's not my type
of game right
the edgeworlds dlc i will i'll play it
but that's like an
when i screamed but unfortunately my mic
was muted when a
people have slept on obsidian because
they've always had a shoestring budget
to make an rpg
i always said if you gave obsidian a
budget they would be
probably number one or number two rpg
creators and they didn't disappoint it
was dark so that confirms the whole
pillars of eternity universe
and i it looks okay cool i could i could
take that i already know obsidian's
gonna make a good game i don't have to
worry
and it's like notes too not for me it's
for a lot of people
i mean it looked okay
not really tipped either way right
hellblade disappointed they showed
nothing
i i was almost in a way they didn't need
to be there
i mean the only [ __ ] fact that they
didn't show anything new they just
talked about it in iceland or whatever
it is and that was pretty much it right
from my understand
yeah it is that's all they said and i
was like okay cool you could have kept
that like
you know
you could have kept that unless you were
going to show gameplay or an extended
trailer or something you know
okay so we got past that and it started
getting this is the lull you know apart
from the
well evoked game yeah it was available
it was fine
then destiny 2 coming to game pass
that was
huge i was like hang on a minute yo
they just dropped the bomb
they must have paid bungie something
the bag was dropped off
because
you take a popular game and go oh yeah
by the way just playing game pass
that and you get the dlc
yo i mean it's that that's a big w
although it's not a new announcement
right
it's it's you know it's a cool
announcement like stalker 2 that that is
yeah i forgot about stalkers
it's like
do you know how old stalker like shadow
chernobyl is and for that for the sequel
to come out so first of all the console
first
xbox is kind of crazy like
big following for soccer yeah there is
still good
i will probably look at it but i mean it
wasn't like a big height moment it was
like oh that's actually pretty cool but
it wasn't oh i'm gonna get super hyped
right then warhammer 40k
you're good
that's your whole genre
i'm like yo i need a good warhammer game
they didn't disappoint they showed me as
soon as i hit soon as he said where's
the inquisitor i was like that's
warhammer
there's no way
um it looks good it looks a good first
person sure yeah and
i mean if if it's done right you'll be
good
then the gunk looks pretty good but not
for me
um but this is a good new look then
medium wow that that medium is
that looks like it's going to be crazy
being able to just slip between each
world yeah and especially if they do it
at random as well you'll be running away
from someone and all of a sudden it just
switches the world on you that's ssd
flexing and architecture for sure oh
yeah that's that's a technical
showpiece and i'm sure that's gonna be
reviewed by digital findery absolutely
on how to actually get that done so that
was a good technical piece i i will play
it
pretty hard for it so it's cool the
fantasy star on line two the new game in
the series i mean i like fantasy star so
i'll play it but
yeah but it doesn't move the needle
right anyway
and then fable i mean
it was as soon as i saw the little
theory and i was like hey it is fable
playground games came up i was like okay
they can put out granted there was no
gameplay but i didn't really expect
gameplay right uh because how far along
what about how short it was though in
the sense of like it was quick it was in
and out it was in it real quick
it was clearly a teaser trailer um just
the teaser i'm sure we'll see more of it
later on in the year but
it was just nice to know yo you know
we've had the rumors for years now that
fable's in the works and here's your
fable so
it's overall it's a good showing all
right so
yeah
i forgot
i've got in the pre-show the exo mecca
game yeah that's all i am so sold these
mechs i i love mech games and it's like
mecca dinosaurs this
makes fire each other i'm like yo
that's a playground right there leave me
there i'll see you next year
uh
dragon quest eleven also come into game
pass was
pretty big announcement huge that was
people don't understand you so overall
you said well what was your score again
just so i know
i'll give it
i'll give it
but stuck between a seven and an eight
seven point five
seven point five yeah there were some
points still kind of exciting i mean
just some of the filler stuff and and
some stuff that you saw before but
overall you still have subtitles that
you did careful oh yeah this is plenty
for me to play there i'm happy with it
it wasn't an amazing show it wasn't a
trash show it was a good show no doubt
so i'll take it solve let's get the um
you know what i'm saying let's get the
super chats
hold on a second
i gotta jump to that moment hold on a
second
no hold on i was looking at the last
dude okay we have loud nose noises jerry
jerry
with the follow super chat
about fable and stalker 2 for me
everything else in the bushes 6 out of
10 show for me hashtag language language
language oh 6 out of ten at least he
likes something like three
then we got drunken ninja with the two
dollar super chat was halo running on
xbox one that's disrespectful
that's disrespectful how are you gonna
do them like that juggernaut even though
the texas i will say well older but the
frame rate door in the environment but
i'm gonna let you rock i'm gonna let you
ride very messy why don't let me get one
away right quick let me give it away
that's the whole thing right now i was
talking about the weight oh the giant
last time xbox drops the hammer and
didn't even show hellblade del david
king they will be collecting knees and
feelings it was a great show nine out of
ten halo new gameplay was awesome okay
okay okay all right
what's the next movement got christopher
hart oh another super chat um halo did
not have ray tracing it looks current
gen
king that was not killing ps5 showcase
period but halo open world
i'm gonna say this christopher hart um
no hold on hold on hold on i gotta i got
a back king shout out to shinobi right
now halo infinite details via igem a
platform for the future last standalone
halo release for the foreseeable future
not a live service but new stories told
under the infinite umbrella and free
race tracing update at large so okay so
um
um afterload
free registration update after launch
sorry yeah um
let me explain a couple of things just
real quick because you know you don't
superchat much and when you do i want to
give you your respect because you come
here every week and you take you know a
beating
and and a lot of dudes you know would
would have gave up or don't give you a
respect i give you a total respect i
love the fact that you do stand and you
stand your ground um i'm not taking
anything away from the playstation show
the playstation show like i said i gave
it to eight i gave this show at eight
this is the only two caveats that's the
difference between this show and your
show your show two consoles that's how
you got the bump with the four normally
you would've got a four because it was
only four games that i was going to go
purchase right every game here is
released in game pass
you can't get hyped for anything but
those four games because financially you
got to make choices i don't have to make
one choice other than the choice to go
to the store what store i'm gonna
purchase my series x from and what day
i'm gonna sit there and try every last
game that i saw so if i was amazed
intrigued or even put off by something i
have the option to try you don't
that's the difference sir no doubt shout
out to message this prime hit me up
saying halo midfield oh
they disrespectful they disrespectful
son they're coming for the halo they're
not
that that fear that what's up what's he
what's up slovo look man i got what you
call it we got um blaze i don't i think
plays have to go everybody have to go
he's been quiet for the whole time but
anyway look solved let's get it man
all right um
i overall i gave it an eight okay um i i
enjoyed it i like the variety i like the
pacing so let me let's go game my game
right let's go halo i think
it feels to me like the slip space
engine is created for efficiency
for speed i think what they're trying to
achieve with halo is to is is buttery
smooth
um
back to classics back to basics in a way
that in terms of gameplay and in terms
of what they're trying to do with the
world the world looked huge the skybox
were crazy it looked like you could see
something and go to it that is
impressive to me i'm excited about that
right um i just thought
and i and i figured this when we first
saw the we saw the first trailer
the simplicity of of of the way the game
looks the game looks very smooth
everything no it's not super texture
heavy it doesn't feel that way right
makes it look simplistic in a way that
didn't that part of it didn't
necessarily impress me the way
the way the game played was pure halo
everything else impressed me about it
it's just like
the look of it did the textures weren't
like super crazy crazy yeah i agree so
that so
but again if they're building it as a
platform like you just said the ray
tracing wasn't there um
i really want to see that when
everything is on and popping and see and
see what it does for my feelings on the
way it looks but apart from that i i do
think they're on the right track with
what they need to do with the halo fan
base and what they need to do to impress
the halo phone coming for you eraser gun
they said the damage controller is so
delicious iop
it runs great it looks great
in terms of smoothness and whatnot i
know they're looking for that i just
wasn't impressed like just ask him for a
date maybe ask him
you know listen if you feel that i'm
damaged controlling anything
ask yourself what will you be playing
this year on your playstation and give
me a date you had a date that says it's
all about the date yeah just give me a
date cause i'm gonna tell you this i'm
pretty sure that buck snacks is gonna be
a launch title and i'm pretty sure the
godfall is gonna be a launch title other
than bug snacks and godfall and you're
you're lucky to get bug snacks you're
lucky to get bug snacks you know
stop it please oh i mean again i'm
calling in spade a spade i don't
understand where where the
where i'm i'm out of the way
because again like i said the game
everything around the engine seems fine
except the look of it look very this
gentle mm-hmm
maybe if we see it in 4k later on today
4k 60 later on today i mean obviously
with all the bells and whistles turned
on
so that
that that was that state of decay the
fact they even spoke about it to me was
impressive to me
okay so they're really in this um i'm
excited to see what it is if it's more
in the vein of what we know of state of
decay right or if they really go on
going in on this mmo thing that they
always sort of wanted to do
um so it's gonna be interesting to see
what that is again i like the fact that
the zombie animals are a thing um it
shows that they're going bonkers with
this universe i just really want to see
how it looks and runs right because
that's instead of the case uh thing yeah
engine and quality we got to see when it
comes down to real gameplay but it
definitely looked like they got a budget
and we liked the direction
exactly oh forza i'm excited for the
fact that
i talked about like this past week about
i don't want to see the nurburgring
again which you probably will but
at the same time
the fact that they didn't necessarily
say it's a launch title
means that if it maybe isn't and maybe
they're leading a little bit more into
grid for you know as they're racing oh
no that's that's not a launch title yeah
all right so then this thing is coming
to next year so the update to horizon
right and and running at 120 is going to
be what kind of showcases the the system
at launch
vibe is fake forza is going to take a
break out of that window that they
normally drop and that rumor is is pref
might be spring of when it's going down
so that's fantastic we know it's going
to look good we know it's going to show
off what the what the system can do
um
everwild really
like
turn the corner for me like everyone
look i saw it
when they originally showed it it was
pretty but it was pretty kind of like in
a grainy way like that's like okay and
it was very like they they went to the
drawing board and they were like
expanding on this it looked like a
cartoon solve them animations my guy
yeah it absolutely looked kind of
fantastic like and if the open world
does anything
even remotely in vain resembling breath
of the wild or anything like that
if the story is fantastic this could be
a big time sleeper because it is a
beautiful game
impressive what they did with that
absolutely
tell me why again i i haven't played i
haven't really played the place
i hadn't played any life of strings and
i know
that first step firstly they do tell
tale better than telltale bro right
right
engine continue
yeah and
from the beginning the engine is better
right and it's been improved for the x
you can tell it's been approved for the
x so the fact that this is coming from
dope not and specifically for the xbox
it is fantastic um maybe i'll play it
i'm not sure um
what they're doing with ori like already
running at 120 is like wow like it's
just again it's it it's already but
but auri was always been beautiful and
the fact that they're up upgrading it
like that is fantastic same for the
outer worlds the outer worlds i i loved
that game i haven't finished it yet so
i'm i'm excited to finish it on the x
with you know
improvements to frame rates
facts and the dlc reveal was cool i mean
if you're going to see it anywhere we're
going to see it here so right you know
that was fine by me uh i know i didn't
like seeing grounded but i never i
didn't play the demo so to see it here
in a more sort of polished state that
looked better i can see how people like
i can see how people would like this
game people like it i mean not for me
but people do like it people say it runs
well they love the the the art community
the guys that's in that survive they say
it's funny yeah they said it's one of
the best design listen this is not for
me i can't even i'm not even going to
tell you this
if you really scared of spiders in real
life like when you see this giant fight
and i thought it was just like one
spider no there's a bunch of them all i
gotta disagree i would have preferred
that that to see it here no no
you didn't want to see grounded that's
what you didn't want to
with that we so we take the grounded
right yes and then right after we get a
vowel oh don't see that's why i forgave
them because i said okay y'all did a
studio package so y'all see yesterday
everybody it was like a posse cut and
everybody got dick first but i was like
big daddy
i said yes
addict has to bend the knee to you
because i think this whole thing was
really about your whole opinion
or studios having multiple layers
that was my victory yeah it's like all
the studios had multiple players things
going on
they never think about it that way right
like
more often than not we haven't heard
that you know apart from playground or
whatever we haven't necessarily heard
that these studios have multiple teams
working on multiple things but we
figured whatever that one thing
everybody's working on yes and then you
have three things coming out of obsidian
and you know they're working on the
outer world sequel yeah as well yes but
a vow to me and
what he did exactly what king said when
he was at king's field i was like oh
whoa hold up that's what it felt like
you know we spent hours i was playing
action yeah if it's anything resembling
that and kind of delving deeper into the
the pillars of eternity law because the
thing about push-up attorney is
fantastic but again
that sort of isometric view turns off a
lot of people it doesn't feel although
those crpd's are fantastic and they're
deep in rpgs you ever find but the
aesthetic does turn a lot of people off
especially on the console side if you're
a pc gamer you're used to it right on
the console side so give me that the
same depth
and like a first person rpg or a third
person rpg you're gonna have more eyes
on it so the fact that it feels like
they're doing that would have vowed
i'm really excited for it like i'm
really super excited for that so beyond
that um as dust falls i agree like if
this could be another thing sort of in
the vein of the walking dead or
something like that telltale i'm not
necessarily a fan of like the moving
pictures and
whatever like whatever i was
disappointed that we didn't get a little
bit of hellblade game yeah hellblade was
oh i gotta
it's not that we don't want to hear from
them but if you're going to come out
don't show what you just showed the
gamer boy and just just make a little
announcement and that was it like unless
they were going to come out and be like
we'll see you in august yeah so if you
would've had a date like yeah but to
come back out you just yeah
like you came for hardcore nobody really
was asking for
exactly unless you go show something
else but continue
again a lot of people maybe felt that
belong there it's still it's coming out
as a third-party game so it's coming to
every platform basically um but again
you have to remember psychonauts
is intrinsically related to xbox like
the original cyclone arts was on first
before it was anyplace else yes on the
near ogx box um that's where people got
the love for that that's where a lot of
people discovered double fine games so
as an xbox thing yes it's i think it's
still gonna it's gonna have it's it's
naysayers but it definitely has its fans
and you know the no date yet though
they've been working on this game for
like seven years six seven years
something like that so i i'm happy for
y'all with your destiny yeah
you don't care
like i said before that's we stalker 2
next to stalker
yo dude like you don't understand like
stalker was one of those games like when
you first played on pc you're like oh
it's just it's it's a horror base for
the first person shooter in in chernobyl
and sort of giving you the scenario like
what happens if you go to chernobyl and
like
they shut that that place off because
they didn't want the rest of the world
to find out what happened you know
obviously what happened there but the
remnants of what happened there right um
but it's also somewhat of a survival
game like if you look at the metro
series the metro takes it sort of in a
different route um it's a little more
action-oriented stalker stalkers a
little bit of both right so i'm
interested to see how they evolved the
stalker formula um and the fact that
it's coming to xbox and first off
is that what that means is coming first
to xbox period yeah um and not pc yeah
that's fantastic again 40 warhammer i'm
not a big warhammer guy they dropped
down a dozen
but the games that we here's the thing i
wanna this part i'm gonna say when i get
to me
we gotta say this for the games that a
lot of us don't care about individually
we all got our games that we care i feel
all of us right but to get a lot of
these are huge franchises that appeal to
a certain group i would say but yeah and
warhammer is one of them because i don't
blame him but i know about that game but
continue
exactly and the love people have for
warhammer like people who people just
salivate at a brand new warhammer right
so um
so that let me see what else so tetris
tetris effect to me i again i play i got
to play it in vr and that's a whole
different experience and i know king
probably played as well in vr it's a
different experience this multiplayer
thing is very cool though what they're
trying to do with it um so and the fact
that i just i was happy to add a cat
that had yeah you get that he had the
whole lap
game
yo for sure
honestly the gunk looked crazy and steam
world all these steam world games are
fantastic that's why when i like it was
like steamworld dig steamworld heist all
of those games are like fantastic metro
2d metroidvania type games um if we get
that
in a third person game yeah
like you know it kind of gives me that
you know minus the first person stuff
that that sort of uh like metroid prime
vibe where is that in in in in third
person or first person so i'm glad to
see that the to me my standout what's
the standout the mediums the
even if it's dirty though will it still
be assigned that way
i'm gonna be yes even if it's thirty if
it's even though they haven't confirmed
yeah yeah confirmed but
to me if they show
why they need to do what they're doing
and it has to be reality at the same
time wow
you know i'm one of those guys like i
was really excited for the blair witch
project um
i love i love that
disgusting yeah
no the framework was horrible and then i
was like wait a minute do they did they
drop it on pc at the same time and the
answer was yes i went right to the pc
yeah that was the pc one oh beautiful
smooth but
on the console i don't even know if they
fixed it on the console they may not
know i would have never i once i
downloaded a matter of fact thank you
for reminding me i gotta go delete that
i'm done but if you want to play the
game play
i'm not gonna do that
overall like real quick again the
crossfire the remedy first person i'm in
on that for just for the remedy first
person stuff and of course fable like
last year at e3 i sat next to attic oh
and you had to see how he sunk when he
got he was right like he was depressed
i've never seen him so sad yeah
he was just like they didn't do it he
got his his jpeg today yeah
the fact that they confirmed it i'm glad
i would have liked to have seen
something just a little bit more
don't be all hyped with this fabled
stuff because remember they showed us
fable before oh that legend i don't know
let's see we see hopefully in a
peterbolli situation i'm sure that they
know that they can't do legends again
right that's not it has to be a core rpg
right fable game um
so i to me again
the variety was there
you know some of some of the bangers
that we thought were going to be there
obviously weren't there right um
i don't want to sit here and say
oh let's wait till august state you know
i don't know we ain't doing that we're
doing it oh i didn't want to say that
yeah um but i think what they did show
and what they've been touting all along
is like we have we have variety that you
can't you're not going to find any place
else and because on other platforms
you're going to find that variety
specifically on playstation you're going
to find that variety from sort of their
second party like partnerships and stuff
like that right most of this is coming
from that from that
um and then
when you look at the fact that you have
multiple teams working within different
studios
you can you're going to get smaller
games in those pockets where you don't
have these huge releases but i'm sure
like i'm sure
most of these teams most of these
studios have a team working on something
that can be considered close to aaa and
then they have smaller things on the
side so
it's exciting to see
some of that stuff starting to come to
fruition
i'm happy about that
um i was again slightly underwhelmed
with with halo just from a look
perspective but everything else felt
like halo and i
my excitement last night i was playing
halo 3. right um just to kind of get in
there and move for it um and if
watching what i watched today felt like
what i was playing yesterday so i'm like
they got it back in that regard it's
just a matter of story and and
everything else they do to see if halo's
really back but it was a good first step
no doubt no doubt let me just get the
super chat then i'll get mine we gotta
get out of here
i got wilbo gaggings uh i think i'm good
too
yeah shout out to him with rj5 i thought
the show was good but will it be enough
to convince people to buy a series x
time will tell no halo no hell blade was
frustrating as hell 7.5 i could dig that
i could dig that and then let's see so
that was blueball um then we got perfect
shogun
five dollar super chat state of decay
three shook me when i saw the said deer
can't be but it was if it wasn't that
work i would have screamed
i think i for whatever reason that's
super exciting to me the fact that
now everything can kill you it seems
like right
it seems exciting robert olsen halo 5
hey looks fire sony fans wish they had
halo 60 frames per second baby
oh oh
big clouds in the building king
stuff out of super chat somebody check
on the homie david oh as if you are in
mourning as if you uh are gonna take a a
huge out today what do you feel about
this gig i didn't take no one else what
are you talking about
i mean
you know you know what the the sad part
is about the playstation fan talk to me
the playstation fan
you guys
keep trying to look for reasons to
deflect or what your show was about and
what's going on
and and i realized today
we are totally two different paths
you guys are playing catch up mm-hmm
yo you guys are battling our warm-ups oh
blackie here he said you don't put bad
elves in the chest black i don't even
know why black is in here
oh they go blaze yeah somebody somebody
turn down put him give him his sleeping
pills put him back
anyway
you know the playstation fan y'all
playing catch up to our warm-ups like
y'all are worrying about pre-show stuff
we have overflow it's too much stuff
that is overflow you're getting dates on
on games that's coming out this year you
saw everything that's inside game pass
and literally everything is something
that you're playing this year
you don't have you're playing ketchup
you don't have a service that's close
you don't you don't even do 60 frames
per second my guy i can't even look you
in your eyes like you are literally in
the last generation you're playing catch
up to your playstation pro all you got
is a playstation pro with a ssd it's a
playstation
that's all you got oh okay
you go with it uh-oh listen i'm really
i'm really tired of these tcl dudes
because
is that is that the point right now
y'all are happy to to gain subpar y'all
told us to literally
to beg kick scream and yell at microsoft
to do us better we've done that could
you please do the same i'm sick and
tired of your basement gaming
yo and you know what i gotta shame you
playstation dudes because a lot of you
do say i don't need a pro because you
know um
i don't see the difference of course
you're not gonna see the difference
because you're playing on a tcl you're
never going to see the difference if you
keep basement gaming you're never going
to see the difference if everything is
going to be at 1080p and 30 frames per
second and you're happy there if you're
happy there don't upgrade there's no
reason for you to upgrade but i saw 60
frames per second today i saw 120 frames
per second and you guys will never see
those those numbers you won't see those
enough you don't even get a date so
please tell me when miles morales is
coming out because i got miles morales
right here where's mouth around your
kingdom going in coach are you getting
psycho nuts
i'm getting psychonauts you're not
dumb games blade x them gays look so
paul ice cold blade x checker boy 4k let
let blaze talk let's let's all right
we're going to get
let's let's solve and give his numbers
and let blaze tell you exactly how blade
felt because that's a playstation dude
and he's going to get a series x and
he's going to tell you exactly why
no no no doubt so
did you finish your bars i didn't know
you got yours
out yeah right the two dollar super chat
whoa dragon quest and game pass baby
that's big that's a big
game this understates
square enix huge
yeah those games never come to xbox like
that's the fact that we got a brother
game before tape
wow
the game pass added one
i already know your destiny bias was it
bro i
and thank you for finally showing fable
the medium was a surprise no doubt no
doubt let's get it in man um yo blaze
bro i've been asking for you came back i
was worried we gotta get the playstation
nation's vibe on this
look
they start off they start off extremely
strong okay
look whether you like it or not it's
halo it's the halo st boot that halo
is serious mm-hmm
looks serious bro you can just tell
it's running on just pure muscle like a
maxed out mustang it just it looks
really clean but it looks like a
refinement to halo it looks like a
refreshment to halo but it just looks
it's the same [ __ ] you love with
with the little fleet yo it looks halo
hold on halo looks incredible i don't
care you can't tap and say it don't it
does but slo-mo said that blade the old
flight station they should turn it on
you they said blaze stop it slow-mo said
was the tcl's the blame for the weak
facial animations or halo infinite i
killed our kid halo look good but not
amazing needs to see more
hold on facial animation has never been
halo strong first of all if you talk
about like the naughty dogs the rocks
are fine but you don't need facial
animations when you're wearing a helmet
okay
number one but two
i want to just say my standouts right
let's go halo was incredible
crossfire
incredible um
dave davis said uh tetris that was on
ps4 as a vr title i'm glad i'm on the
xbox now
um what was the other one forza
obviously force is going to look great
you guys can say oh they didn't show
much but it's forza it's it's solidified
bro okay it is what it is and then the
uh the game warhammer that looks so dope
to me i'm a big warhammer guy look you
guys can say what you want oh they
showed a little uh filler psychonauts
whatever at the end of the day like he's
saying if you have game pass that's not
a big pitch for you you're only going to
spend five dollars and you're going to
be
five dollars so instead of the
playstation guys look it is what it is
now as a playstation guy i gotta go drop
20 30 40 whatever these indies cost i
might have to go drop it if i want to
play
that's what he means by that but was it
a better show than the ps5 you know what
no oh
let's get it
let's get to the playstation 5 showcase
no no he's going to tell you he's going
to tell you why watch this let's go why
is the playstation 5 showcase better
that's what christopher hart said he
said it was better
it was better because look look first of
all you had the excitement of the
console at the end because
that's it
what'd you say what did you say
because that hat he's wearing
your will he just told you the console
at the end if they don't show that
console let me ask you this something
blaze if they don't show that console
who had the better show
i'll talk to you out there
please don't give it up
flip the place for standing on the
square so look that's the real stand on
your square move right there i respect
that i respect that
look i'm just showing look i think i
think they were similar like yo i think
they were super similar
other than i honestly i think they were
they stand um
they both were dude they both were simon
from the game game game game other than
the transitions that king don't like but
they were literally showing
blaze shotgun
he said you under the rest he said blaze
you surrounded by xbox guys it's okay
okay so you know more talking to you
no more this pcl playstation stuff if
you're not super chat we ain't listening
continue we got money let the man get
his balls let's get his balls up my face
we gonna get the super chats
look i think there were even shows
but like i said look i'm look you see me
i'm now now i've been i've been not
biased i've been trying real facts but
at the end of the day they both showed
these
you know they both showed look fable is
a big announcement did they show
anything no but you know what i got
criticized for certain games that they
showed an announcement didn't show
anything so
i think there was similar shows i just
think the the console reveal of
playstation just knocks stronger because
wow we've been waiting and waiting for
anything anything that's why i say i
give it to playstation because
they show game game game and then they
show the console and that solidified the
whole conference you know without that
console mm-hmm
then it's different no you keep it up
you're saying that you can't be true you
can't be true so so look real quick how
do we go along um
what was did you get you gave your
rating did you give your rating and then
what was your standout
game like what was the the moment here
for you
look
look it's it's got to be
it's got to be halo i mean that's what
we've all watched
when i told you my top five games all
the times i told you it was halo right
i'm a playstation like you guys can all
be blaze smoking weed like what no they
said gary potter's saying this man is
under the influence they said blaze fear
for his life blaze looking weak out
reading none of that stuff unless it's
in super chat no more
love
my bad kick my bad
let the man get his bars off no more tco
reading
they got
you want him to spit your bars please
okay so i care about my kid smoking i'm
sorry i can't playstation tcl nation
i'm not allowed
blade access i'm weak i'm looking weak
out here why because i own seven [ __ ]
ps4
talk you talk you got everything
like stop it like i'm just being look
was it i told you playstation had the
better show i told you why you guys look
you guys you guys gotta be [ __ ] look
can you guys be honest
look they both had good they both were
decent shows like what do you want me to
say you want me to sit here and lie like
yo this is family to me first of all i
think i'm playing people on you're crazy
crazy that's number two
they had great shows i'm i'm saying i'm
giving it the place because in the
console and i believe ooh i love
playstation i can't help it i can't say
sony took an l1
they can't take that
they they don't take it out of my dick
blaze what's the score i give it up i
give it uh i think they started off
strong and they kind of dwindled a
little bit okay i'm gonna give it a you
know
yes i hit that score though please i'm
gonna give it up i'm gonna give it a
seven oh okay okay i was curious i was
curious
because he gave the playstation 108.
he's still on the screen
we remember because i remember you gave
me remember i remember yo
i'm getting super
state of decay avowed omg ever wild
fable and halo let these folks pay 40 to
snack on bugs i'll be eating i'll be
eating good at the game past
absolutely oh let me get my shout out
the lord's a game with that damn buzz
you already know poland in the house
selling some chess solid show seven out
of seven point five out of ten forza
truly looks next-gen okay you bought
then we got shroom kingdom with two
dollar super chat ponies don't have game
pass they can't super chat
did we get neal mental two dollar super
chat you should never smoke crack
stream bro damn
okay
kai wait hold on wait wait i missed it
that jumped me crazy
we have kaibatsu oh guys
personal excitement should not be a
criteria for show ratings hello king
stop well stop saying
i see a lot and and i'm respecting
you with ponies
i respect that because he put his money
up to talk all you other dudes with that
tcl stuff you're in the bushes man and
you high scene dudes you don't think i'm
really i don't really even recognize you
the heising dudes you know who i'm
talking about y'all below tco
[Music]
then we got super panda again wait no no
we got shroom kingdom two dollars so
ponies don't have game pass they can't
super chat oh hey yeah
real talk though agree with blaze shows
were similar all games in game pass put
xbox over the edge for me
good point good point and now we're
caught up look i'll make it quick
because we went super low now look man
this was i gave it i gave it an eight
i'm just gonna go straight to it the
reason why i gave it this was a weird
show and the reason why it was weird
because i felt they started off strong
they had to hit the halo first of all
the pre-show to be honest had a couple
of gems in there that was crazy the
dragon quest the um what you call it the
robot game i forgot the name of the mech
joint you know what i'm saying they had
a couple of joints in there so the
overall pace of the pre-show could have
went in the bushes though but those
announcements that we got as little
extra was a good look for the
announcements now the show itself they
went straight to halo started off silky
love to see the max level a lot i'm with
soft though i felt textures with connor
last jenny you know what i'm saying but
it was smooth like it was super silky
smooth classic feel now i'm one of the
new school guys that like the sprinting
and all that but if the bass don't want
that remember i'm not i love halo but i
wouldn't say i'm in the hardcore halo
like the way i'm destiny so if the bass
wants that and they giving the bass what
they want i i can't be mad i'm playing
that it looked good i thought that was a
standout i thought crossfire was huge
every while blew me away i i i
really did and i i laughed at that game
at the third party show i was i mean i
was i was just like yeah
it but for what they show rare impressed
me with that man so shout out to that
fable at the end you know that was that
was it was a huge deal that it existed
you know what i'm saying i felt this the
reason why this show was weird
because i felt
everybody got something
they really wanted and then a lot of
stuff they didn't care about right yeah
so
for me
i got to look at it as a w for diversity
right because everyone came away from
that each one of y'all the power came
away from that show with something that
he like oh my god like for me i am
destiny bias forte what's up when i
heard they went back home
marketing or game i'm it's over that's
all i i'm good like i am so gucci with
that situation so i'm like okay they got
me on that but then there was some games
and i was like yo
every while crossfire look great medium
look crazy you know what i'm saying like
just to switch it to the stuff back and
forth and they had a lot of moments that
i'm like yo xbox would have never had a
game like that before yeah you know what
i'm saying oh can i say something yeah
go for it play playground games make and
fable you gotta understand now that's no
more horizon you know for a little bit
but here's why this way i disagree the
playground is a huge team they like they
wanted the biggest so what they proved
especially obsidian
because that first i go for a hell blade
was a l off rick because i'm like you
shouldn't even showed up if you're gonna
show the whole thing but
where they won was okay we're gonna give
you this out of worlds dlc right
then we're gonna show you this new joint
that we're working on you know what i'm
saying so so now you're showing me that
you can't you're not just gonna do the
one remember the complaint was all these
dudes just doing passive projects
grounded you know whatever whatever nah
that's out now you know what i'm saying
we're doing four things at once whatever
your flavor so again
this show is one of them is one of them
hustle shows whatever you want what you
want you like this oh you don't like
that oh wait what about this it's one of
those so i could see how someone can
come away and say hey it wasn't for me
but this game right or i could see how
each subset of people warhammer you know
say all these different groups that what
came away with the joint for them and i
think ultimately as much as people may
say or the show as a whole they gonna
say it was an eight or nine or whatever
i if that's your feeling i can respect
it
but
for what actually sells consoles at the
diversity of games that's what sells
consoles y'all that literally
playstation one of their keys to success
was all these different style of game
the only one l for me
gotta say all
i think i didn't get the just one i
didn't get the hashtag just one
i didn't get it i didn't get that i
didn't i didn't get that and and for the
people who don't know what hashtag just
one is it was uh xbox studio ip
new ip yeah over the shoulder
cinematic obsidian came close but it was
first person you know what i'm saying a
couple of games came close but they
weren't of the joint you know i'm saying
shout out to steak to decay though even
though that wasn't that's a sequel you
know whatever whatever that looked
probably stated the k dude i'm sorry
cgi yeah yeah yeah it's vertical slice
it's vertical slide there's no but i
just like
the direction that they go and i know
they're gonna have an engine because we
had the desks we had our dead labs on
they they got when they we had them on
they had got signed by
xbox studios right at that time
but they didn't we didn't know that they
didn't have the budget they didn't have
they wouldn't even use it in the servers
and all that remember it was a whole big
controversy when they lost we was like
yo with the rubber band and then right
and they had them a lot he said it was
memory issues a lot he just literally
said it was a resource thing now they
got the budget and a better engine let's
go that was a huge surprise for state of
decay fans that's a redemption you gotta
understand for a lot of people but look
i gave overall like i said i thought it
was a i thought it had a little bit for
everybody i could see though people
walking away and say hey it's a six or
seven i could understand that because
they may say hey it's not for you but
his dear king wins and i know people
coming at my boy and trying to say like
he took some alice up
i can't say that when
80 percent of this game you know what
the show really went this was a win for
game pass
every 80 percent at least was in game
pass you know what i'm saying so that's
number one that is a huge advantage for
them coming in and then the number two
we gotta stay uh sony for sony nation
you know i respect
but he's right about release dates y'all
what with these games a lot of these
games are coming or they telling you
they're coming you know what i mean so
even if you say like you didn't like
some of those games okay fine
but there's a huge subset of people that
did and they're like yo i like that war
they got this i like that they got this
one and it's coming so that's what it is
it's just gonna be one of those type of
joists overall i thought it was solid
and we got to see what happened august
man first shots firing shots on both
sides i can't wait man it's a fun guy
let me ask you a quick question what's
up bro
but like a lot of the games that are
coming like other than the halos the
fours are um medium
medium the obsidian joint look you know
can you
like can those games be made see these
games are going to be on xbox right
right right
you know i mean so what what i'm just
saying look what other than the halos
obviously the big ones
what are the you know what's saying hey
this is screaming next gen like this guy
oh i feel where you going
i'll give you this place outside of
media go in on this hold on all right
i'm gonna get you there i'm just gonna
let you go outside of medium and
crossfire i'm with you blake i don't
feel any of that look from a next-gen
looking perspective right i know where
you're going like i i didn't feel
anything was like oh my god this is a
completely reason why this looks
next-gen i feel that but i'm gonna let
ken get his bottle because he clearly
neither one of these shows showed you
anything that was next
not one show not one not that
playstation show and not this xbox show
right if you do just gonna stand on that
square stand on the square for real the
only reason why they telling you that
you can't play these games because they
don't have no backup plan you can't play
their games because they want you to buy
a playstation 5. they cannot tell you
you have the option to sit back and wait
because they still go on my old matrix
all right right now you have game pass
this was a game pass show
right so if right now if you're thinking
if you're smart if you have any iota of
brain you said to yourself yo you know
what let me book up this game pass for
the rest of the year right
because all those games i'm gonna get to
play
you don't have that option with the
playstation what you're saying is when
can i pre-order miles morales dlc that's
supposed to be playable on my
playstation 4. but they get not giving
you the option to do that how many
people will forego anything with the
playstation 5. if they if if all those
games because i didn't see the ratchet
go play ratchet and clank right now
ratchet and clank looks the same maybe
the frame rate looks a little bit better
maybe it's a little bit more particle
effects on the screen so listen stop
capping
they cap it
none of these consoles showed you
something that can't be done on the
current gen if they want to really use
your playstation pro a lot of you tcl
dudes are pass out so
right now is the frame rate and i
understand that may seem far into a lot
of you do
it's the frame rate and it's the is the
resolution because your tvs can't do it
it's the truth all of us all of us all
of these all of us on this panel right
now have tvs that can handle everything
we saw so we still king saying what
king's saying is hdmi 2.1 which allows
you to play a 4k hundred twenty thank
you
like so we are saying it's about damn
time
right you've been holding us back you're
not holding us back no longer all right
so anything you gonna either you're
gonna get a playstation five and you're
gonna probably see some 1440p some 30
frames per second you're gonna finally
catch up or you're gonna get a series x
with this game pass and you're gonna get
this work but you're not gonna tell me
this i'm gonna tell you this take all of
microsoft shows right you wanna go show
for show
take all of these shows take all the
console reveals take the austin evans
take the digital foundry take the
breakdown take everything you are
slaughtered you have nothing
the same way i told hip-hop gamer i put
up what we got on launch date against
anything like
you have a question mark you're walking
around like a people from whoville you
don't know what's going on where is
going on and what you got to get
questions
they don't know they've released large
titles
they have no idea when they put name
money down all you know is miles morales
you got a dlc that you're gonna put 65
no now it's 70 bucks you keep 70 bucks
in on a eight hour dlc
please throw yourself in the bushes god
freaking tired of you dudes with your
tlc's get your tv game up and stop
worrying about stuff yo worry about
getting the tv game up don't worry about
blaze
blaze is in good hands because i'm gonna
tell you right now when y'all sitting
there high scanning it up
your man is gonna be sticking with the
series x when y'all sitting there trying
to figure out if godfall is actually
gonna do 60 or it's gonna do 30
he gonna be playing halo
now
if if you take that playstation console
away from your show
you walked away with nothing
and blaze knows it i'm not holding
blade's feet to the fire i'm not gonna
do that that's my guy right there we
talk in the background so i'm gonna
respect his square he's standing there
as a representative of you guys please
give a better representation of your guy
he's being real with you but y'all show
y'all had nothing
add everything up and we blow you away
y'all tuned in today
oh please all please ain't standing for
that you're playing
kill me right now let's go and add all
the shows up let's go
break down your console how big is your
console
what did your console really look like
did we see the insides of your console
so right now you playing catch up right
thank you we who same boat don't let me
do this to you on air oh my god blaze
come on bro you can't come on you know
you no no no where's your breakdown let
your break you go let's let's play my
brother you're gonna tell me when the
breakdown let's get your balls off get
your balls on blaze if you're gonna
compare the x to the ps5
look yours looks like you know a little
where's the breakdown hold on you almost
look like a like a dodge challenger i
look like a tesla okay so
my time out where did you see the
console at
or did you see a render
that's the real thing though no no no
where is the console
who has it in their hands
not me did austin evans have it the
digital foundry get a chance to break it
down
did anybody open it up and see if it
really works or are you giving a bunch
of vaporware do we understand or do we
not know i don't want to do this to you
on it no no you got to do it you're my
guy you're my guy y'all know my thing
but what but for real look right right
right you're looking at the launch
lineups right whatever you know even
people say the xbox one had a better
launch line but did you buy a
playstation you know the games are
coming you i don't care about the launch
line i'm buying it to get into the
ecosystem so i know what's coming you
know what i mean like my hope right bro
you hope they survive they ain't never
had to know
you know what listen listen guys y'all
never had fill on your neck
phil is on your neck right now you might
not even make it out of the two years
because i'm gonna tell you right now if
y'all have that same mishap that we had
in the beginning it ain't no redemption
it ain't no recovery y'all do going
multiplat you're not gonna make it out
and if y'all think i'm joking i'm dead
serious listen listen i like energy but
y'all y'all are gonna lose three to one
he's my guy and no i did not ever want
to do this but remember
no no new tco playstation fanboy flame
torch tiki torch dudes
your dudes are in the dudes that's not
super chatting right now
you know why they're not stupid right
because they got to buy games this year
yo you stupid you stupid they're making
choices they making choices because they
ain't got the game i see the vision i
see the visions i see what you're doing
i see what you're doing so to find out
for the game fans could have went to the
super chat so they could serve it okay i
got you i got you i got it let me make
something clear bro i feel your energy
look i just i don't want to go there
with you i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
just because i got a level of respect
for you guys i don't want to go
but i can get real i can get real mark
cerny on people i don't know how you're
gonna get down there
to send you your ears
it's crazy let's get the super chat so
we got it we got a big cow game with the
final super chat talk that talk king
then we got smitty smith with the final
super chat shame them king shame them
tcl and high senses not the move
little argument we [ __ ] watching
crazy was that slow-mo when he jumped me
give me a second all right all right go
ahead i'll refresh my trying to help you
out
all right yeah last one you read was who
was um
so slow-mo says high sense cooperation
demands king david immediately stops
landing towards us and the brand we are
at least on par with tcl but definitely
better than westinghouse
then we got the wise old gamer a vile
giving off those doctor strange vibes no
doubt no doubt you got drunk and ninja
you caught about it i could get the rest
of you needed no i got drunk and ninja 2
super chat a lot of games only had xbox
series x and pc on them though that's
true oh tony bryant find out
xbox confirmed on twitter all game shows
all the games yeah wow
wow
that definitely changes everything
everything if that is confirmed y'all i
need a double
but if that is the case if every game is
on game that's a huge advantage y'all
regardless of how people may feel about
it but we'll see it's over that is huge
that's
on your neck you're going you're going
to purchase your console and that's it
you don't need and then chances are
they're giving you at least a month free
in the box yeah i got to say you got to
see how they fly
i swear i got without being
disrespectful i'll get it get it get it
blade in that series i i swear i mean
this with my like a thousand like you
suppose
y'all are playing catch up to us oh
that's the fact that they won the gym
y'all know how that goes i know
well the gen is messed up because now
game pass and sales are all messed up
now but i'm just saying look
it like
it's going to be bad for you guys
follow the leader follow the leader
right it's going to be bad bro but if
xbox can deliver great first look look
if they can deliver some bangers people
will start changing their tone real fast
let me ask you a question
real real quick show that real quick
okay no no it's not it's not in right
now
right now all right so you have 135
million sold right yeah 135 let's give
you 150.
i'ma boost you
how many of that 150 brought um last of
us
how
many four i'm gonna give you the number
four million
uh all right first week how many first
week
and then it was eighty percent off next
week
um
okay now now let's really get to these
numbers right mm-hmm
go to sashima right
fire goes to fire
150 million of you dudes right mm-hmm
150 mil
how many purchase
how many purchase
did you crack a million
did you crack a million i don't really
think so no no
no no now check this number
game pass is up
65
last numbers you heard was 12 million
add that up
so it's the game
your back is broke
right now your back is by
stop it gotta be a message
better back compact more powerful
console most games today on game pass
why would i not get series x some
fanboys are in denial hashtag b
wise wow
try wazzo gamer okay yeah yeah then we
got midway monster with the follow
school chat it takes years for games to
look next gen in my opinion yeah so 110
dedicated to the next gen after launch
titles xbox up 50 mil to what yeah zero
next gen yeah
it is what it is are we oh we finished
it caught up i believe so wait nope
blue moon pc with the five house which
i feel like i did in two thousand five
five great show fellas a little bit yo
425 i can't believe y'all still in here
man this is crazy just the hell it's red
and rave but look
salute to y'all man this is this is
tremendous the show we all had our
feelings on it you know we'd be back in
the realm you know so we're gonna do
these outros right quick little william
you still rocking with us man i know
you're doing the marathon what else to
scream to the man um of course i'm here
man i've had a lot of calls from my
employees
can't get up with me but yeah i'm still
here i appreciate you brother first of
all thanks for rocking us first live
reaction where can the five people find
you and what you got going on sir
well you can find me every wednesday
night at 8 00 p.m on aiming beyond the
box
me the forking crew and whoever we
decide to bring on
uh you can find me on xbox playstation
pc and i did just cancel my stadium
because i think i'm the only person that
watched their event
but i mean you can find me anywhere
there's a game to be played
i've probably got it and played it and i
do want to stand up for mr blaze yes me
and this dude are friends on pc no blaze
is a gamer fax more people need to be
gamers and quit the whole fanboy
narrative it just gets old after a while
one thing about the homie blaze man he
got everything too just like you you
know what i'm saying oh yeah about
everything so it's a little bit salute
to your team
and on what channel can we find gamers
behind the box sir
uh look up will me will me hood on
youtube
i got a promo
and and i'm on twitch twitter facebook i
mean if you can type in will me hood
into google there's gonna be a long
string of stuff that pops up you already
know salute brother that was a lot of
fun we definitely gotta pick you back
scream did you fall asleep you're still
with us brother
scream baby in the bushes he's still
beauty oh he's back scream what's going
on bro
he's unmuted but we can't hear you
no he's really in the bushes all right
we'll get back can you hear me now okay
there you go there you go scream talk to
the people man where can the people find
you what you got going on sir
uh you can find me on youtube uh
if you type in wilhelm scream destiny
i'm sure i'll pop up on there and see
him on uh on twitter nice nice some of
the best for having me here absolute
pleasure a lot of fun
always a pleasure man promote this band
we'll scream one of the best destiny
content creators out this guy will get
your stuff in ways you didn't think
possible but let's just say that all
that he's humble we humble but now he's
a real dude man please support scream if
you like destiny which is now a game
pass
you could uh go check that out because
he he's definitely he's definitely one
of the best in the game that's lou and
of course we got def sega xbox uk
royalty of the building what's going on
sir making the 501 what what up thanks
for having me great show yes and
you can find me on xbox pc
and
no doubt deaf singer what's up and of
course
the legend sony baby on his square even
though accusing us of bullying but the
man was fighting here he was on the
square repping he had his gear wrong he
was here standing tall one of the what
first of all shout out to blaze
forget all the gaming stuff like this is
a real dude y'all like we
rocks with blaze like blaze is one of
the most coolest if you get to know him
forget all the fanboy stuff if you got
misconceptions until you talk and play
with this man real is dude man salute to
him blaze where can i find people find
you what you got going on sir
and you went away when i gave you some
bars damn i gave you bars right now you
just went away
blaze is in the bushes but it's all good
he'll be back later you you talking to
sony right now
lord's off where can the five you find
what you got going on sir uh you can
find me racing to work right now
i'm sorry but you guys can catch me uh
of course lordstop iop on twitter
caspy picks up and on ps1 xbox live this
sunday should be interesting
got some things to talk about we haven't
even picked
the other topics for the rest of my god
i know it might not even be the way this
is going to go this is going yeah
exactly
um and real quick uh neil mental with
the five household chat at the end of
the day it's all love and jokes
get this gaming in peace y'all facts
facts let's go yeah man hold the big
cloud gaming in the chat brother we're
gonna get you on too you already know
yeah blaze one of the realest for sure
for sure you already know
and
the king
standing on his square gave us 12 days
of xbox leading in
bars is on deck
ready stood on the square where can the
five people find you but you gotta go to
us sir you can find me on twitter
beating the brakes off these dudes with
these t-shirts tcl shaving today
no man because you know what it is is
you know these dudes they are not going
to six
4k game they're not going to 60 frames
per second and a lot of these dudes
ain't even going to jump up and get a
playstation 5. i got to respect a lot of
the playstation dudes listen if i hit
y'all in the dms you all already know
that i really messed with you no doubt
you know um i messed with uh blaze and
at no point in time i said today
or am i going to uh tell them if they're
you know catching up or whatever but
again
you know we're not going to move no goal
post we're not going to be moving stuff
around everybody's going to stand on a
square i gave the playstation show at
eight i gave this show a eight yeah
there's a different different reason for
why i gave them shows and eight you know
um some stuff i do not agree with today
i did not agree with a lot of stuff that
was in there i'm not playing a lot of
that stuff for now i'll shake my head at
you no no that's real um but it's in
game pass and what i don't play my son
definitely will play because he has game
pass so um
be real gamers
you know everybody that was on this
panel uh shout out to you guys for even
hanging out with us this long and
watching the show and spending your time
with us
yes shout out to boom
for securing something that he's been
chasing and i really respect it hard
work does pay off people uh always be
respectful and be kind and individuals
so i would like to tip my hat and uh
drinks up to everybody that had a great
day
every gamer wins today
and today is a day of choice
so you can choose to follow me on
twitter
lloyd king kingdavidotw
on twitter same thing on uh xbox live
and on playstation
is xbox 360 level 01. you can catch me
playing go to sushima
you already know there's cognito here
man salute to y'all man to the chat
macho channel i've seen i've seen lots
of gaming.net up in here see a lot of
people up in here man salute man
everybody you know we're gonna come back
with y'all probably um you already got
the kicker statues up right now checked
it out mars morales in the building king
got another one you already know
supportlordsofgaming.net
thank y'all for rocking man this is fun
we like doing these reactions you know
what i'm saying and salute to the chat
it don't matter what size you're on the
fact that you're out here y'all getting
y'all bars off and according to king and
color we good
yeah cco dude put it in
sunday you know the lords will return yo
everybody please